Das war's für heute.
Vielen Dank für's Zuschauen.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Das war's für heute.
The
so auf geht's
ha guck mal heute ist der der fodja oder wie er heißt nicht da zuerst sonst ist der
ha guck mal heute ist der die kinder
hat
da
ich bin ganz schön im arsch mal gucken wie viele feiferts sachen wir hinkriegen aber ich habe jetzt schon glaube ich
vier fünf tage glaube vier tage ist nicht mal gestreamt ich glaube das reicht
Machen wir auto update bei new tech ja vielleicht und manchmal gucken so was in der richtung also was wir heute machen
Moment
Ja jetzt muss ich noch was schreiben war ganz gut minuten was der sekunde
Leute kommen immer zu super super günstigen
Zeitpunkten der anruf was schreiben
Ja da sage ich da sage ich gleich was zu da sage ich gleich was zu
Bisschen laut
Bisschen was zackigeres kommen
Exzellent
Oh zu ja ja ich sage ich sage ich sage gleich was zu
Alexanders
R Dave
Oh zu ja ja ich sage ich sage ich sage gleich was zu
Also
ok
kurz um anfangen
ich ich sehe nicht weil was sie oben geschrieben würde weil weil
Ja wahrscheinlich werden wir sowas in der richtung machen ich weiß auch nicht ob es push bei new tech
Aber mal was mal gucken was in der richtung auf jeden fall wir machen zumindest auch nicht die richtig hardcore variante mit
Verwaltet sich komplett selbst und update sich komplett selbst synchron zu dem was im github ist
In die richtung in der richtung müssen wir mal gucken was da ich zeige euch übrigens auch mal was cooles was ich auf github gefunden habe
Wo ich glaube das ist sehr praktisch was heißt auf github ja doch ist auf github das könnte recht praktisch sein für alle
Aber ich kann auch erst mal was
zu meiner o2 geschichte erzählen mit
Der telefonnummer
O mann leute das ist echt absoluter wahnsinn die sind so extrem unfähig wieder
Ich werde jeden tag auf twitter posten
Ich mache agocd
looks cd habe ich noch nicht habe ich keinen plan von
So wobei sich das glaube ich ich habe ich habe damals ein oder andere video drüber geguckt gar nicht so viel nimmt
Also flux cd kenne ich nur wir haben auf der arbeit flux cd oder flux wie immer man das dann richtig ausspricht
lasst das mit dem warum warum ist das ok jetzt musst du mich überzeugen warum ist flux besser als
Jetzt muss er jetzt muss er auch mich überzeugen woran es liegt
Also der eine oder andere der bei mir auf twitter am start ist der wird ja vielleicht schon gesehen haben
Kann sich auch einfach beides angucken und an das passende nehmen
Der wird ja schon gesehen haben dass ich also übrigens leute ich bin jetzt ganz offiziell
nicht der wendler
Ganz ganz offiziell
Hab ich mir nix zu schulden kommen lassen guck dir warum hat das eigentlich 160 like so random einfach 160 likes
Weil ich keine eintragung habe auf meinem führungszeug ist also leute ich habe mir den vertrag geholt bei o2
weil
Ich habe wir haben das sogar im stream gemacht
Wir haben anbieter verglichen
Und sind zu dem schluss gekommen
Das o2 für mich das beste angebot hat preisleistungstechnisch
und dass ich mehrere
datenkarten haben kann
Und dass ich e sims haben kann multisims haben kann so fand ich ganz gut preislich ist auch ok 40 gigabyte im monat für
Keine ahnung ich habe es vergessen
zumindest ich habe mir ein o2
Starter set bestellt bei denen oder so ein o2 set mit dem vertrag zusammen kam per post und dann habe ich das ganze
aktiviert morgens
Denkt man sich ja nichts böses dabei ja man legt simkarten ins handy
geht auf die aktivierungswebseite
gibt seine puck und seine
Simkarten nummer ein und was es da noch alles gibt
Muss namen eingeben und zeug und dann ist gut das ist mir gar zu klassisch mario hier jetzt
Exzellent
Und
Wo ist mein twitter jetzt hin habe ich mein twitter auf
Terraform ne mit terraform mache ich heute eh nix
Ok zumindest
Hat das aktivieren der simkarte funktioniert und nachdem du deine simkarte aktiviert hast steht ja auch in dieser
o2 start anleitung drinne soll man sich einfach einen o2 account dann mit dieser nummer erstellen und dann kann man sich dann
Damit einloggen und dann kann man dann alle möglichen sachen sehen und vor allem kann man auch die
Rufnummern portierung direkt über das web interface beauftragen also in seinem account also kein problem simkarte aktiviert
versucht account anzulegen
Und jedes mal wenn ich mich einlogge in mein account kommt das hier ich sehe nichts in meinem account also ich kann weder gucken wieviel habe ich verbraucht
Wie viel ist noch übrig ich kann auch keine rufnummer portierung beauftragen
Ich kann auch keine rufnummer portierung beauftragen
Oder wie viel ist noch übrig ich kann auch keine rufnummer portierung beauftragen
Wohlgemerkt
Könnte ich theoretisch über ein formular eine rufnummern übernahme beauftragen aber ganz im ernst
Ich möchte nicht meine rufnummer zu einem account umziehen oder bei einem anbieter bleiben
Der nicht in der lage ist die einfachsten dinger auf die reihe zu bekommen nämlich
einen login in meinen account
Du hast die schon seit über einem jahr na geil so zumindest
Was habe ich gemacht?
Ich habe bei der hotline angerufen und die hotline hat gemeint da da müssen sie warten einen tag
Ich habe den ich habe den dann auch noch gefragt so das haben sie sich jetzt nur ausgedacht oder um mich zu beruhigen also das wird morgen auch nicht gehen
Doch doch das wirkt drehen na okay habe ich mir gedacht naja
Übliche beruhigungsversuche wird wahrscheinlich nicht so wird wahrscheinlich nicht stimmen
Zwischenzeitlich noch ein bisschen auf twitter gepostet die leute verrückt gemacht noch mal hotline angerufen der hotline typ meinte
Oh das sieht aber merkwürdig aus
Und sagt ich muss kurz rücksprache halten also wohlgemerkt der zweite hotline typ ich muss kurz rücksprache halten
Und dann hat er mich 30 minuten in die warte schleife gelegt und auf einmal war ich weg
Dann habe ich ein bisschen rumgespammt
Dann habe ich ein bisschen rumgespammt auf twitter ich meine man sieht es ja hier
Ich habe hier gemeckert über
Ich habe hier gemeckert über über o2 und ich habe hier gemeckert über o2
und irgendwann
Bin ich dann auf die idee gekommen ich könnte mich ja mal
Bei
Alter
Gatschi gatschi bus man
Twitter please
Musst ja schon aufpassen wo du auf seinem eigenen profil runter scrollst man
Ich war ich war kurz ich trau mich nicht weiter zu scrollen ich trau mich nicht weiter zu scrollen keine ahnung was da gleich kommt
Zumindest irgendwann hat dann auch einer von o2 ich muss jetzt wirklich aufpassen wo ich hier so dann hat er
Dann einer bei o2 geschrieben sie können hier eigentlich auch nix machen
Ich soll mal ich soll mal in die community ich soll mal in die community gehen
Ich kann nicht drücken ich bin nicht mal eingeloggt
Also sie zeigen tossbeiträge wenn man nicht eingeloggt ist also bin ich bin ich in die o2 community und habe folgenden thread aufgemacht
Man
Also ich finde ich habe das den passenden user name gewählt für meinen und auch den passenden avatar für meine
community beiträge
So und ich habe die o2 community gefragt simkarte aktiviert blablabla gibt fehler wenn ich mich einloggen kann ich muss ich muss
Ach ja das habe ich ja ganz vergessen zu erzählen
Da ist irgendwas total kaputt weil der erste typ bei der hotline hat mich mit falschem namen
Angeredet der weiß ja eigentlich wie ich heiße und er meinte her k. Punkt ich heiße nicht kam mit anfangs buchstabe nachname
Herr k. Punkt was wer zum teufel ist her k. Punkt also bei denen ist irgendwas total im arsch vielleicht hatte her k. Punkt vor 20
Jahren war die gleiche ruftnummer ich weiß es nicht zumindest
Aber ich
Ich aufgemacht so weiter geht es dann wurden dann wurden haben
Das sind ja übrigens keine also auch wenn niemand denkt dass in wohnen von mitarbeiter sind keine wohnen von mitarbeiter das sind freiwillige community helfer
Da habe ich das habe ich schon gemacht kein problem ich bin ja nicht der übelste k. Punkt wenn ich das dann lese
Als hätte ich das nicht gemacht ja
Als hätte ich nicht passwort vergessen gemacht na gut weiter weiter bla bla bla bla bla bla
So und irgendwann habe ich dann mein gift gepostet hier habe ich den gift gepostet wie ich mich einlogge und wie es halt nicht geht
Ich logge mich mit der ruftnummer ein und es geht nicht
Also ich weiß die leute werden jetzt wieder verlangsamen gucken ob ich hier gerade irgendwo meine ruftnummer geleakt habe oder mein passwort vielleicht geleakt habe
Oder so habe ich aber nicht
gut
Einer person gefällt das wer gefällt das autokat ja gefällt das ok mal katja find es nice dass ich
Gifts poste high high iq user mögen sie
So also bla bla bla und da liegt ein technisches problem vor ach nee
Ok
Und jetzt kommt jennifer um die ecke das muss ich ja sagen also auch wenn ich jetzt ein bisschen auf autos schimpfe
Jennifer gibt sich zumindest mühe
Jennifer hat es bis jetzt schon nicht hinbekommen dass es funktioniert beziehungsweise die kann das ja nicht machen sie kann ja nur ihre
Support das ist jennifer als first level support die hat weder ahnung davon noch hat sie rechte dazu was zu machen
das muss ja auch als first level support nicht
Und sie hat es verstanden und sie kümmert sich drum so jennifer hat ein ticket aufgemacht
Jennifer hat ein ticket aufgemacht und dieses ticket wurde ein tag später geschlossen
Mit der meldung per sms der fehler ist behoben
Selbstverständlich war der fehler nicht behoben ich glaube so viel so viel ist schon mal klar wenn ich jetzt schon das würde ich
euch das ja nicht erzählen der fehler war selbstverständlich nachdem das ticket geschlossen wurde nicht behoben
Also dann geht es noch weiter bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla
Jennifer hat erkannt woran es liegt also jennifer weiß zumindest schon mal ein bisschen mehr als der nur nach 15 first level support
Also sie blickt da schon ein bisschen mehr durch
So bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla
so
Und dann habe ich ich poste da jetzt auch jeden tag ich poste als jeden tag ein tag gewartet und es geht immer noch nicht
Ticket ist aufgemacht so jetzt hat sie ein zweites weiteres ticket aufgemacht in der hoffnung es wird das alles ein wenig
Beschleunigen es geht immer noch nicht weiterhin gleicher fehler mit paar stunden abstand dazwischen
So und heute morgen hat sie geschrieben das ticket ist es ist sehr bedauerlich das ticket ist immer noch da habe ich nichts mehr drauf geantwortet
Weil wisst ihr was ich jetzt gemacht habe in der zwischenzeit achso und dann dann habe ich mich dazu entschieden
Ich werde jetzt jeden tag auf twitter
posten
Can't do
Dass es immer noch nicht geht so natürlich natürlich bin ich ja nicht total bescheuert
Was habe ich gemacht ich habe mir ein aldi torque starter set geholt
Und habe heute ein aldi ein aldi torque starter set aktiviert und habe bei aldi torque die rufnummer mitnahme beauftragt
Was innerhalb von acht stunden funktioniert hat also den termin zur ruftnummer also
Aldi torque hat aktiviert account angelegt ich habe ruftnummer mitnahme beantragt die haben jetzt gesagt nächste woche mittwoch wird die ruftnummer umgezogen
also aldi doch hat es alles innerhalb von
7 8 stunden komplett hinbekommen abgewickelt und das obwohl ich mich verschrieben hatte
Bei der ruftnummer portierung die erst abgelehnt wurde also ich habe mehrere ruftnummer portierung anfragen allesamt gleich nach hat funktioniert
Aldi torque ging einfach so jetzt ist die sache
Ich werde folgendes machen das habe ich übrigens jennifer auch geschrieben sagt eigentlich ist es zu spät ich habe jetzt bin jetzt schon bei einem anderen anbieter
Aber ich lasse es weiter laufen leute ich lasse es weiter laufen
Und wenn es nur ist um jeden tag auf den sack zu gehen
Ich poste jetzt jeden tag in diesem thread dass es nicht funktioniert und ich poste jeden tag
Auf twitter dass es nicht funktioniert das wird nämlich o2
Ich wieder rufe den vertrag nicht ich wieder rufe den vertrag nicht ich bezahle dafür die 12 euro im monat nur um o2 flamen zu können
Das ist mir egal
Und vielleicht kriegen sie es ja hin ich kann die ruftnummer doch noch portieren dann halt von aldi dahin
Und jetzt kommt jetzt kommt der hit
Jetzt kommt der hit
Es haben schon meinen tweet von heute morgen dass es o2 wieder nicht hinbekommen hat
Wieder nicht hinbekommen hat über
10.000 leute gesehen man hat jetzt ja neuerdings gescheite analytics für für die für die tweets über
10.000 leute haben den tweet gesehen also wissen dass ich mache das so lange
bis entweder
irgendein marketing mensch von o2 einschreiten muss
Oder sonst was keine ahnung
Also ich werde ich werde jeden tag ich werde jeden tag posten hier und ich werde jeden tag auf twitter posten
Einfach nur um die abzufacken
Marcel davis ist nicht von o2
Aber die sehen auch blau die sind auch blau von dem anbieter wo der herkommt
Also
Also leute das wird jetzt das wird jetzt jeden tag leider leider gezwungenermaßen
Wir feiern den zwei millionsten kommentar war ich das vielleicht
Wer verfasst moment
Fakt ich habe es ich habe knapp ich habe knapp verpasst
Den o2 kenne du gemt der für mich jeden tag postet ich poste schon selbst das mache ich das poste ich selbst
Also ich werde ich werde den jetzt jeden tag
Ich werde den jetzt jeden tag posten ich werde den jetzt jeden tag posten ich werde den jetzt jeden tag posten
Also ich werde ich werde den jetzt jeden tag gehöre ich auf den sack gehen
Und wie gesagt über 10.000 bis morgen sind 15.000 leute leute ich habe euch miss erzählt offiziell also bei mir in der app ich sehe
Schon über 10.000 aber leute
Ah, nee, okay, okay, whoo, aber mal klück gehabt noch mal klück gehabt doch kein mist erzählt
Nee das das bleibt nur der bahn vorenthalten atheno dankeschön für den sub
Warum hat der bahnheit eigentlich abgenommen ganz einfach
Ich habe zwar immer noch die ansage dass ich gefälligst 50 prozent beziehungsweise zwei tage bei mir die woche
Im büro sein soll aber ich mache das einfach nicht mehr
Und ich denke mir so ey
Schmeißt mich doch raus wenn es euch nicht gefällt
Weil ich habe ja eh schon gekündigt zu ende des monats
Die können im prinzip einfach gar nichts mehr machen was sollen sie machen ja
Ich fahre einfach nicht mehr hin zweimal die woche und einmal die woche halte ich irgendwie aus mit der bahn
Kannst du generell was zu deinem kubernetes ja kubernetes kubernetes kubernetes
Hier ist ja auch die frage ist es k8s oder ist es kates habe ich auch schon gehört wobei ich sagen muss kates
Ist irgendwie sehr unvorteilhaft die abkürzung
Ja kann ich was zu sagen das ist die simpelste variant die es überhaupt gibt zum ausprobieren lokal mit minikube das ist kein cluster
Ich habe kein extra note irgendwie jeder heim und raspberry pi oder sonst was wir machen das ganz billig
In der vm mit minikube und docker drin fertig braucht man ja auch nicht brauchen wir ein riesen cluster um ein bisschen rum zu basteln
Ansonsten in zukunft ist es höchstwahrscheinlich fast ausschließlich google cloud
Und da bin ich mir noch nicht ganz sicher
Wie gut weil aktuell ist es also bei meinem aktuellen arbeitgeber ist es es kubernetes also man managt
Wie hat man das managt hostet also
Es ist kubernetes service
Und in zukunft ist wahrscheinlich hauptsächlich google
Und da bin ich mir noch nicht sicher wie gut
Die geschichte mit google autopilot mit dem kubernetes autopilot funktioniert ob man vielleicht sogar noch weniger selbst managen muss
Bei dem google kubernetes cluster mit autopilot wie ohnehin schon
Mal gucken wie gut das taug das weiß ich nicht habe ich keine praktischen erfahrungen mit
Ansonsten in zukunft wahrscheinlich aus ausschließlich oder nahezu ausschließlich google
Kubernetes
Soll er machen selbst wenn er mir ein schlechtes zeugnis ausstellt wird mich das nicht jucken
Ich habe nun super poggers zwischenzeugnis wird schwierig das irgendwie jetzt zu begründen
Meinung zum thema als start up in die cloud
Das ist wahrscheinlich das beste was du machen kannst
Also es kommt natürlich ein bisschen auf deinen service und die größ an wenn du in ein mann entwickler bist
Der noch nicht mal irgendwie einen ordentlichen prototyp am laufen hat
Wenn du einfach nur ein bisschen was online stellen willst kannst auch eine vm nehmen mit
Der anwendung drauf und im reverse proxy davor also man muss es ja nicht übertreiben und
Selbst wenn zufälligerweise pewdiepie ein video über deinen service macht kannst du immer noch mal auf die schnelle ram und cpu hochskalieren
Gut ist das dürfte unterm strich wahrscheinlich die einfachste variant und auch die billigste variant sein
Und naja gut
Der vorteil ist davon du musst dich weder mit serverless geschichten noch mit kubernetes und sonst was beschäftigen du kannst es einfach
relativ schnell aufstehen ich meine ganz im ernst vm
Ich weiß leute die die sich gut mit kubernetes ausgehen die sagen so überhaupt kein akt kubernetes cluster ist schnell aufwärts das stimmt das stimmt man muss aber
an ganz vielen stellvertretungen
Dass man es eben gescheit macht
Wenn man bisschen liebungserfahrung hat ist so eine vm-easy angelegt web interface clip click Vaater und drauf
Ja aber wenn man ein bisschen bisschen was größeres forum finde ich ist das die logische die logische konsequenzen weil was bleibt
Dir denn realistisch hierarchاي niemand der sayt belongs in deiner工作stelle
Also so dieses reais vastly
Etwa in der kunstprinenger
Bleibt dir denn realistisch betrachtet als datum anderes übrig eigenes rechenzentrum wirst ja wohl kaum betreiben können
Und bei der wayne vm ist auch klaut solange sie nicht auf deinem esx läuft
Also
Wissen wir ist kein eigenes rechenzentrum betreiben wollen du hast auch weder du hast auch nicht die anbindung dafür um dir mal
Irgendwie den server und dann schreibt dich zu stellen
Also ich finde gerade für start ups ist die logische konsequenz eigentlich in krempel in der cloud zu hosten
Sofern ich
irgendwelche
Ich zum beispiel datenschutzgründe oder so
Dagegen sprechen je nachdem was das startup macht ja flubio du kannst ja ein bisschen was erzählen vielleicht können wir mehr dazu sagen
Damit wollte ich mich noch beschäftigen habe ich nicht
Es gibt ja noch mehr möglichkeiten für lokale installation als minikube minikube ist ja noch nicht mal dafür gedacht dass man darauf wirklich sachen laufen lässt
Sondern das ist für lokales basteln gedacht
K3s ist quasi so ein light weight kubernetes was weniger ram braucht weniger cpu braucht und ich glaube die sagen selbst sie sind besonders gut geeignet für
zum beispiel irgendwie
self-hosted raspberry pi cluster und solche geschichten
so was hat der
Der twingo eigentlich jetzt zu flux geschrieben ich finde einfach den ansatz von flux besser wir haben von argots ja flux weil es einfach besser in den
nativen kubernetes ansatz passt
Okay es schadet ja nix sich mit allen möglichen sachen mal zu beschäftigen
Also du kannst ja limits setzen wo habt ihr die wo habt ihr die vor einem laufe bei google oder wie
Ja also du kannst bei den meisten cloud anbietern ja irgendwelche limits setzen
Was du was du ausgeben kannst
Also du kannst ja limits setzen bei google oder wie
Ja
Das kann man so pauschal nicht sagen ich glaube es kommt drauf an
Was man für leute hat wenn man hauptsächlich leute hat die sich
mit linux die linux hintergrund haben
Dann ist wahrscheinlich eine vm mit linux drauf einfacher zu betreiben für die weil serverless allein jetzt irgendwie ein paar
zeilen dotnet
java python sonstige go was halt beliebte sprache dafür sind
in irgendein funktion workload pappen ist ja das eine aber du hast ja
Damit noch kein service der gescheit funktioniert du hast einen endpunkt den du aufrufen kannst der dann irgendwelche statischen dinger ausgeben kann oder so
Das ist ja nicht in uns weg das sagen du brauchst dann auch noch
Du brauchst dann auch noch irgendwie die möglichkeit dann zeug persistent zu machen du musst ja noch die passende cloud datenbank dazu verwenden
Dies ja jeder große cloud anbieter hat aber musst du dich auch damit auseinandersetzen also ich denke wenn du viele leute mit linux hintergrund hast ist
linux vm sich mieten
Darauf
postgres zu installieren und
in den
Dienst drauf zu klatschen im reverse proxy davor wahrscheinlich einfacher
Als ich erst mal in irgendwelche cloud native entwicklung einzuarbeiten wenn man wiederum leute hat die sich damit auskennen
Dann ist das
Wahrscheinlich unterm strich die einfachere sache also wenn man mal davon ausgeht dass du leute hast die sich mit beidem gut auskennt
Dann hast du recht dann ist wahrscheinlich dass die einfachere variante aber das kann man ja nicht nicht unbedingt voraussetzen
Das ist richtig ja
Also gut ich meine cloud also google google cloud ist für vm ist jetzt auch nicht unbedingt besser
Als als ova oder hetsner oder sonst was mein du hast natürlich mehr auswahl im google ökosystem vm ist vm
Ich muss sagen ich bin jetzt noch nicht mal gucken beim neuen arbeitgeber verwenden wir ja bloß noch google cloud also da werde ich mich in zukunft
Wahrscheinlich dann auch besser mit auskennen
Ich bin jetzt zum aktuellen zeitpunkt nicht der riesen google cloud
Experte ja also keine ahnung was sie dir alles anbieten du kannst da sicherlich auch vms hoher und runter skalieren und sonst was
Im endeffekt ist es eine vm wenn ihr halt im google ökosystem seid
Habt ihr die chance noch mehr von denen zu verwenden ihr könnt zum beispiel die
Im endeffekt ist ist eine vm wenn ihr halt im google ökosystem seid
Die hausend postgres geschichte von denen ist sehr nice wenn man sich leisten kann oder man einen bock drauf hat
oder generell
Managed;; managen bank also ich denke wenn man das dann wirklich sich dafür entscheidet
Seine sachen in der cloud zu betreiben dann sollte man es auch richtig machen
Also sprich dann kann man auch
Managed datenbank verwenden
Und man kann die managed
Container registry verwenden
und
irgendein managed
No sql datenbank oder was auch immer oder ein managed wenn man das denn wirklich wenn man denn eben was gut
Containerisieren kann an seinen anwendung auch eine managed kubernetes
Gerade mit autopilot soll das ziemlich gut sein wobei ich wie gesagt habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert
Ja deswegen also wie gesagt die dinger sind meist bei asia auch also
viel billiger als ova und hetzner wirst du bei google garantiert nicht recht nicht hinkommen und
Also die haben ja auch ordentliche ordentliche
Oms im angebot da kannst du teilweise bei hetzner kannst du glaube ich kisten bis zu 24 kerne oder so mieten
Ja s3 ist natürlich auch was nice ist für persistence muss dir keine gedanken mehr machen um irgendwelche
Filelocks und sonst was also wenn man wenn man wirklich dann in die cloud geht also wenn man sich dafür entschieden hat zu sagen
Hey, wir machen jetzt ein größeres fass auf ich finde dann sollte man es auch richtig machen cloud storage
cloud managed datenbank managed no sql managed container registry alle möglichen dinger die es denn dann so gibt weil
Dann hast du einfach weniger administrativen auffangen man hat anderen administrativen auffangen aber da ist finde ich nicht so groß wie bei einer riesen flotte
lielungskisten die du dich kommt wurde dich selbst komplett drum kümmern muss bei den dinger muss verwalten muss updaten du musst
security
Früher waren es mailinglisten heute muss heute irgendwelche feeds dir angucken
Du musst schauen dass das ding auch
Synchron bleibt zwischen den einzelnen klassen aus dem klassen selbst einrichten das ist alles was das kann man machen bringt aber meistens gar nichts
Ja dann lohnt sich nicht
Also
zumindest nicht das was ich gesagt habe also
Ich
Wenn die dinger so custom sind
Also wenn man die die coolen sachen aus der cloud nicht verwenden kann die einem das leben leichter machen
Dann ist halt auch die die frage obssönig ist ja wobei man halt sagen muss
Was ist einer was ist einer container registry so custom ist dass es nicht geht also ich wüsste gar nicht wie man die
Also
Container registry ist ja eine container registry so
Sie machen ja alle das gleiche
Es ist jetzt nicht so dass die die die docker container registry groß anders ist als die github container registry
von der api vom ansprechen her ja gut aber gut ich war ich weiß ja nicht wie euer zeug ist
Das muss man natürlich dann machen also man muss also finde ich zumindest wenn man den schritt macht von von
selbst gebastelt vms
Zu mehr cloud services dann muss ich es auch lohnen und lohnen finde ich tut sich das nur
Wenn man auch möglichst viel von den bereitgestellten services benutzen kann so dass man halt selbst den aufwand nicht mehr hat
Das ist ja gerade der vorteil an der ganzen cloud geschichte
Wenn ich dann doch wieder alles selber secret manager zum beispiel ja
Ja ist individuelle geschichte muss man gucken ob es das lohnt
Ja
Kollege und ich wir sollten
Vielleicht irgendwann eine eigene consulting firma machen da kann ich den stream dazu benutzen leute zu
Akquirieren soll ich sagen ja dazu kann ich dir alles erzählen was du willst melde dich mal bier bei mir
Ja
Schön hast du den weg her gefunden hat der final faulenzer ach nee der feiner schuld ich habe fein
Faulenzer fragt mich nicht wie ich da drauf gekommen bin
Ne gut jetzt haben wir genug gelabert ich schaue noch mal kurz drüber
Serverless ist gratis naja
Ich weiß nicht ob man das so pauschal sagen kann
Das kommt darauf an wie viel serverless du machst
Also die meisten die serverless machen für die ist es bestimmt nicht gratis
Wenn du im free kontingent bleibst bei deinem jeweiligen anbieter dann ist das gratis
Das ist ein bisschen wie
Bei google maps google maps hat ein relativ großzügiges free kontingent aber danach ist es abfakt teuer
Das ist das google service mit dem habe ich schon erfahrungen gesammelt wir haben also ein kleines projekt gebastelt mit für den ruten planer
Für so wo man so so und das war das war eher so ein so ein
Prototyp was wir da gebaut haben da konnten handwerker konnten eintragen
Wo sie termine gemacht haben
Und wann die termine sind und der ruten planer hat dann den
besten weg errechnet zwischen den kunden dass sie zu der jeweiligen urzeit da sind das ist gar nicht so eins gar nicht so einfach
das ist ja quasi
Wie heißt das so schön traveling salesman problem mit time windows lots
Hab ich natürlich nicht selbst gemacht ich habe eine fertige open source projekt von github benutzt damals
Was
Quasi den ruten planer implementiert hat explizit für
Solche aufgaben fälle und dann auf open street maps zurückgegriffen hat für für die ruten planung
Jetzt ist tatsächlich nicht einfach es ist auch nicht abschließend gelöst aber du kannst mit genug umprobieren gute lösungen finden
Dass das ging ganz gut
Ist nie was draus geworden aber da habe ich da habe ich erfahrungen gesammelt mit mit google maps
Und das ist schon relativ teuer wenn man das freie kontingent überschreitet
Ja das meinte
Github containeregisterie ist ein witz
Für kostenlos also doch eins ganz gut warum ist sie ein witz
Die benutzen wir heute übrigens auch ich mache mal kurz updates ich mache mal kurz updates leute
Vielleicht habe ich wieder corona ich hoffe ja nicht
Heute hat mich ein kollege angeschrieben von der arbeit den ich am mittwoch den ich also mittwoch
Gestern gestern gestern gestern auf der neben mir gesessen hat auf der arbeit gestern und hat gemeint seit heute ist sein test positiv
Und ihr kennt mich ich bilde mir dann auch ein so nach dem motto mir juckts im hals und sowas
Wir werden nicht keck ws service deployen wir machen wieder so ein
Modus wie das hier ist das ist ein modus wie das hier ist das ist ein modus wie das hier ist das ist ein modus wie das hier ist
Wir werden nicht keck ws service deployen wir machen wieder so eine kleine testapp dafür aber ich mach mal ich mach mal hier die
die vm an und mach mal updates nebenbei
Du hattest es auch erst also ich hatte es einmal bisher und mir reicht es
Eine gute sache ist ich mein ich war davor schon geimpft ich habe es mal bekommen
Und
Die neuen varianten sind ja auch quasi noch ein bisschen unschädlicher als das was ich hatte weil ich war wirklich
14 tage oder drei wochen insgesamt also war ich ziemlich im arsch also richtig kacke was war es so eine so eine woche eineinhalb wochen lang
Aber danach ging es irgendwie nur mal zwei wochen bis ich wieder halbwegs fett war es war mega beschissen jetzt will ich nicht noch machen
Ich kann euch sagen das war wirklich wirklich beschissen
Richtig räudig jemanden also schön zu sagen also ich hoffe nicht dass ich das noch mal habe
Es muss wirklich nicht nicht nicht sein
So wo sind wir denn stehen geblieben das letzte mal bei unserem
kubanides gebastelt
Repos minikube das klingt eigentlich ganz gut
Wir haben das letzte mal nur ganz ganz kleine basics gemacht wir haben
Wir haben
Wir haben ein deployment angelegt mit einer test app drinnen mit health check readiness check
den load balancer service davor und ein reverse proxy
Und der keckle keck weh punktservices alles klar
Nice akubanides cluster am start ich glaube mehr haben wir das letzte mal gar nicht gemacht
Das ist die app so heute muss ich mich erstmal auf github einloggen bin ich hier schon eingeloggen fuck
Check
Ehm chat macht ihr die augen zu ihr guckt nicht hin oder
Guckt ihr alle weg
Ich muss mir sicher sein dass ihr weg guckt bevor ich das eingebe ok alles klar ich glaube euch chat ich glaube euch
Ja
Ups wieder hat er gar nicht rein denn ich war reingehen
randomly
Okay bevor, ich mich noch öffentlich verteppern leute
Okay
Ich meine ich hab zwei fuck der un рублей zu τ
Sms code
Okay alles klar da sind wir wieder
Durch den black screen durch geschaut
Gg eats okay also wir legen mal ein neues repo an new repository private
Krasse krasse banger hier am start
Okay weiter also wir brauchen den repository wir machen es jetzt gleich richtig
Ich mache das repo erst mal private weil ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher was ich alles reinpusche
Ich weiß ob ich will dass jeder alles sieht
Ich meine ihr seht alles im stream ja aber ich bin mir nicht sicher ob ich nicht im hintergrund vielleicht da was ein oder andere reinmachen muss
Ich weiß ich will dass man public sieht weiß ich noch nicht deswegen lasse ich erst mal private wenn am ende des streams nix drinne ist
mach ich es public
Okay
Wir machen es jetzt auch richtig wir machen wir machen zwei repos
Wir machen ein repo für unser ganzes kubernetes zeug
Und wir machen ein repo für unsere app die wir dann deployen in kubernetes
Für unser ganzes kubernetes zeug und wir machen ein repo für unsere app die wir dann deployen in kubernetes
So
K8s
Okay private private templates
Ja das wollte ich euch nämlich zeigen das ist gut den packen wir da schon mal rein
Wir brauchen keine readme scheiß drauf
Mit flux kannst du auch ein mono repo betreiben reicht doch in unterschiedliche ordner aufzuteilen
Das kann ich mit agro cd auch machen wenn ich will
Ich kann auch alles da in eins aber ehrlich gesagt
Ich finde es nicht so sinnvoll infrastruktur jammel konflikt für kubernetes und die anwendung ins gleiche repo zu packen
Also man kann es ganz praktischen gründen
Weil du dann immer das gleich immer das repo anfassen muss wenn die anwendung anfassen außerdem was hat die anwendung mit einer kubernetes konflikt zu tun ja eigentlich gar nix
Und im enterprise umfeld oder im business umfeld sind es auch komplett andere konfig zu machen
Aber normalerweise ist ja derjenige der was in der die anwendung entwickelt überhaupt nicht der
Der die basic kubernetes konfig macht da macht vielleicht die ein oder anderen jammel files explizit für seine anwendung dass er die schön deployen kann
Je nachdem wie man es mit berechtigung gemacht hat
Und das ist auch ganz wichtig die anwendung der jammel konfig macht die anwendung der jammel konfig macht die anwendung der jammel konfig
Also
Klonen wir das ganze mal kurz
ne moment
Ich hoffe ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher ich hoffe ich habe mein ssh key hier
Pack
Ich glaube ich muss den von der alten vm holen der alten vm ist da drauf sein exzellent
Mokka ws swan supreme dankeschön für den sub
Mal das hier zumachen
So ssh keys ich muss mir mal kurz mein ssh key rüber kopieren
System ctl start sshd ip habe ich die da ok alles klar
Kurz zeug rüber kopieren
Ich glaube das ist es so
Fuck man welcher welcher key ist es jetzt eigentlich genau kurz checken
Er gibt nicht so viele keys nice ok
Ich glaube ich muss den von der alten vm holen
Da kopiere ich einfach alle rüber
Punkt ssh
Punkt ssh ok was
Hä
Ach so das geht ja gar nicht ne wollte ich gerade sagen das macht der das macht er hier
ähm stimmt wie mach das
Wahrscheinlich muss ich einmal es capen oder
Das ist eine gute frage siehst du mal manchmal kommt man auf ganz simple simple sachen nicht
Ne wie heißt mein user
Ach max lull ok fast fast fast
Ok nice
Jetzt stimmt wahrscheinlich die jetzt stimmt wahrscheinlich die berechtigung nicht
Doch die berechtigung stimmt alles gut
Alter was mit der musik los
So ich glaube jetzt passt das hier können wir da ausmachen so wenn ich jetzt glück habe darf ich mein
Git repo klonen wobei wir alle wissen dass das das jit repo ist
So klonen
Und und und post jam post
Ach so ja das ist weiß ich dass ich dass ich in empty repo geklaunt hat
So also da sind wir drin das ist unser kubernetes repo
Dann
Ja ist eigentlich gut passt doch
Denke ich das kann man erst mal so lassen
Also unser kubernetes repo da machen wir noch mal einen neuen tab auf für unsere app
Du du du du du du du du
New repo cute app
Private habe ich auch private gemacht der private bla bla bla
Etten wir auch hier dazu bei prometis überhaupt egal machen wir mal
Welchen file editor verwendet auf der kommando zeile wim ansonsten studio code
Jetzt haben wir unsere zwei repos angelegt und checken wir das noch mal schnell aus das shit repo
Git klonen
Okay, dann legen wir doch mal los ich bin gerade überlegen mit was war mit was am besten anfangen
Als erstes würde ich sagen starten wir unseren lokalen kubernetes cluster
Weil ansonsten können wir nichts machen solange nicht gestartet ist ich gehe davon aus wir müssen den heute ein paar mal
Starten und stoppen vielleicht sollte ich mir mal irgendwie so ein clean up script oder so bauen
Aber starten wir das ding erst mal ja also noch mal für alle die beim letzten stream nicht dabei gewesen seid
Wenn ihr lokal und wie gesagt das ist nur für lokal zum ausprobieren gedacht
Wenn der lokal ein bisschen mit kubernetes rum basteln wollte dann kann ich euch nur wärmstens minikube ans herz legen das ist ein
Mini kubernetes single node ich glaube man kann es mittlerweile sogar klassen
Sicher zumindest kann sie verschiedene backends verwenden der kann
Das ganze virtualisiert starten der kann das allerdings auch in dem docker container die kubernetes api laufen lassen das reicht schon
Für lokal wie gesagt das ist auch nicht gedacht um dort irgendwelche produktiven apps oder so drin laufen zu lassen ist um lokal in
Auf der linux kiste zu basteln und sachen auszuprobieren das ist nicht gedacht dafür
Irgendwas wichtiges laufen zu lassen ja aber wenn man es dafür benutzt ist es super ja man hat zum beispiel so man hat man hat addons dabei
Man kann zum beispiel direkt
In ingress in engine x ingress installieren lassen das ist quasi so in so eine art reverse proxy
Dass ich meine pots also meine container im cluster laufen lassen kann und trotzdem drauf zugreifen kann und solche geschichten
Ist ganz praktisch
Nächsten stream kann ich euch jetzt gleich sagen nächsten stream werden wir das alles noch ein bisschen
Etwarnster machen
Nämlich dann bauen wir das so dass ich das selbst verwaltet also dass man da nur noch starten muss und sich alles erst mal so selbst installiert was man braucht
Das war mal müssen wir müssen aber dann heute machen wir ein bisschen bisschen was kleines zumal ich auch
Irgendwie ziemlich im arsch bin heute also wo fangen wir denn jetzt am besten mit an
Das letzte mal hatten wir
Ich mach das noch mal auf
Das letzte mal hatten wir was ganz simples gemacht ja so eine hallo welt app die
Mit sechs containern quasi im cluster gelaufen ist ja pots aber meistens in pots auch in container
Wo sechs container im cluster gelaufen sind und wir hatten hells endpunkt wo man checken kann ob die app bereit ist
den load balancer service vor und reverse proxy das war es so was ähnliches werden wir jetzt auch bauen
Ja, genau drachenflieger so sieht es aus so was ähnliches werden wir jetzt auch bauen allerdings
Will ich euch mal
Ein paar sachen zeigen und hier muss ich jetzt noch mal disclaimer sagen
Ich bin nicht der
Krasseste kubernetes stelze auf der welt ja also ich benutze das als nennen wir es mal anwender
Bei uns auf der arbeit
Ich habe da auch schon die deployments angelegt und sachen drüber laufen lassen
Aber ich bin niemand der da jetzt wo ich wo ich selbst sagen würde ich blick da 100 prozentig
Aber ich bin niemand der da jetzt wo ich wo ich selbst sagen würde ich blick da 100 prozentig bei allem durch
So und es gibt einen trend so die letzten jahre über
Das ganze nennt sich get ops hat sich irgend einer wieder einen dollen namen ausgedacht für irgendwas
Und zwar geht es darum so mal um das jetzt in zwei drei setzen zusammenzufassen
dass man seine cluster das ist
Zwei so im kubernetes umfeld entstanden wobei ich bin ich sicher bin ob es da überhaupt wirklich ursprünglich entstanden ist aber zumindest ist es da relativ
Beliebt dass man eben seine cluster nicht mehr von hand administriert ja ich kann jetzt zum beispiel
Muss ich mal kurz den alias anlegen habe ich bei mir auch sonst mittlerweile drinne
Alias
Das ist so richtig schreiben kann
Ich kann zwar die laufenden pots mir anzeigen lassen und solche geschichten
Und
Machst du keine cluster administration in dem fall ja also normalerweise früher hast du es oder nimm als ich
Ne ich mache relativ wenig an denen
Wie nennt man das so an denen
In rein von kubernetes rum wir haben da anwendungen drauf laufen wie gesagt ich habe da auch schon deployments erstellt
Und
Ich gucke mir regelmäßig auch die grafen dazu an wie wie auch immer das ist dann immer
Erkennt man ja recht wenig drauf unsere grafen aber ich habe wie gesagt von den von den internen sachen jetzt nicht so den wahnsinnsplan
Deswegen habe ich mir gedacht bevor ich meinen neuen job anfangen muss ich mich auch ein bisschen mit kubernetes mal
In reihen auseinandersetzen ich meine wie gesagt ich kann das bedienen ich kann da was drauf deployen
ich
Kann einstellen dass das ding drauf skalieren soll es skalieren zwischen einem und sechs pots
Ansonsten habe ich da auch nicht so den wahnsinnigen plan von
Aber das ist das gute mir macht es ja spaß so neue dinger mir anzugucken
Was ist ein pot pot ist quasi ein container in kubernetes wobei das nicht ganz stimmt ein pot ist quasi eine container gruppe
Es muss ein pot muss nicht ein container sein das ist oftmals so aber es gibt auch die möglichkeit dass du in einem pot in kubernetes
also pot ist quasi so eine
so eine so eine container logische container gruppe
du kannst zum beispiel
einen pot starten da ist dann deine anwendung drinne plus
einen weiterer container für logging oder sowas
Das ist dann so eine einheit zusammen ist halt deine anwendung plus noch ein bisschen was was die anwendung brauche zum beispiel secret management oder sowas
könntest du zum beispiel auch noch reinpacken dass du dass du deine passwörter und sowas irgendwie in die anwendung reinkriegst
on the fly dass du da irgendwie noch einen secret manager als als zweiten container im pot laufen hast
dann hast du im endeffekt dann ein pot besteht aus einer anwendung aus irgendeinem monitoring logging container
besteht aus einer anwendung aus irgendeinem monitoring logging container und irgendwas für secrets injecten
hat nichts mit potman zu tun ne und ein pot ist quasi so die kleinste einheit die kubernetes verwaltet
so genau was ich jetzt erzählen wollte und irgendjemand ist dann auf die idee gekommen könnte das ganze ja gitops nennen und zwar
der gedanke dahinter ist dass man seinen cluster nicht mehr von hand administriert so wie wir es jetzt hier am anfang noch machen werden
sondern dass man in git repo hat wo die gesamte cluster konfiguration drinne liegt nicht nur cluster konfiguration ist ja so gar nicht mehr richtig
also alles was in deinem kubernetes cluster läuft nicht nur die nicht nur die config für den kubernetes cluster an sich sondern auch die config für alle
also die manifest sind das die kubernetes jammel files drinne liegt sondern auch für die ganzen anwendungen die da drauf deployed werden
und alles mögliche und so dass das ganze und das machen wir jetzt auch gleich und so dass das ganze gesüngt wird immer sobald einer was pusht
natürlich gibt es da noch paar zwischenschritte die man einbauen kann man muss ja nicht direkt sein cluster quasi an public oder an git repo hängen
sondern man kann ja noch irgendeinen bildstep dazwischen haben der noch irgendwelche checks macht oder berechtigungsstufen dazwischen oder sowas
aber das ist zumindest so der hintergedanke ist man hat ein man hat ein git repo mit der gesamten cluster konfig allem was dazugehört
und man ändert nichts mehr von hand am kubernetes cluster sondern macht das nur noch über config falls im git pusht das und der cluster applied es automatisch
so das ist das ist so die die idee dahinter ist die config dann in den repos secrets ne die config liegt hier ganz normal im repo drinne für den klasse machen wir jetzt mal gleich
und secret management ist tatsächlich ein bisschen kompliziert ok wir fangen mal an so das erste was wir von hand installieren ist argocd
oder ich muss auch gerade lass mich gerade in mich gehen wie fangen wir denn am besten an
die bräuchten bräuchten eigentlich nach einer anwendung ums auszuprobieren egal wir installieren das ganze jetzt mal und gut ist also wir legen jetzt wir legen jetzt mal ein jammel file an
es gibt es gibt verschiedenste arten das das zu installieren aber wir können es ja wir können es auch mal über den jammel file
lass mal kurz was gucken
lass mal kurz was abgucken
ja ich habe heute schon hier mehr sachen gelesen ob argocd oder flux oder sonst was
ok wie dem auch sei ich zeige euch jetzt mal was cooles bevor wir richtig anfangen
so das kopiere ich mir jetzt mal aus was raus was ich schon was schon angelegt habe ich mache das jetzt einfach mal und dann erkläre ich was dazu
so
wie war das jetzt am besten
kann ich mir nämlich aus dem kopf beim besten will nicht merken
ich glaube wir fangen wir fangen bisschen kleiner an ich lasse ich lasse den schitt erst mal weg ich habe da schon ein bisschen was kasse meist für mich deswegen ist
ok also
ich installiere absichtlich mal was altes dass ich euch was zeigen kann so also jetzt erstmal wurscht ich habe eine datei angelegt wo nichts anderes drinne steht wie dass wir das hier installieren und wir installieren argocd was das ist seht ihr gleich
kubectl apply-k punkt
ich bin doof ich habe den namespace vergessen na geil ja das ist halt ein bisschen doof weil man copy pasted aus sachen wo das ganze schon wieder anders ausschaut
moin don't cry so much
wollte mir das jetzt eigentlich aus was raus kopieren wo es schon wo es schon funktioniert
komm wir machen den namespace noch ein
komm wir machen es jetzt richtig
das ist auch ein bisschen
ok jetzt das ganze noch mal
also was im richtigen verzeichnis noch werden
so jetzt wunderbar also wir haben jetzt argocd installiert ich zeige euch jetzt gleich was das ist aber vorher will ich euch noch was auf github zeigen
wo ich finde das ist was richtig was richtig praktisches und zwar renovate wahrscheinlich kennen das die ein oder anderen schon wenn ich zeige euch das mal finde ich was sehr nice ist
github add wir können alles hinzufügen github commit-a-m-init github push wunderbar jetzt gehen wir mal in unser github repo gucken
cute kubernetes zack da sind wir haben das installiert so gucken wir mal was läuft auf unserem kubernetes cluster wir haben jetzt schon ein paar dinger laufen wir haben argocd laufen wir haben die ganzen basic container laufen die startmäßig mit dabei sind und wir haben den reverse proxy laufen
damit ich jetzt darauf zugreifen kann auf argocd muss ich zwei sachen machen
wobei ich wollte euch vorher eigentlich noch was cooles auf github zeigen ich zeige euch jetzt erstmal was cooles auf github so ich habe das jetzt gepusht
und vielleicht ist euch jetzt aufgefallen dass es eigentlich ein issue geben sollte an der stelle müssen wir mal gucken
renovate login ich bin mir nicht sicher was da kommt wenn ich mich einlogge deswegen mache ich euch mal kurz aus eigentlich gar nichts oder cute cute
alles klar da sind wir es ist gelaufen vor ein zwanzig minuten hat aber nix aufgemacht
bisschen leaken schadet nichts ja ach jetzt ok alles gut also ich habe ich habe wirklich cooles projekt gefunden das ganze nennt sich renovate und was das macht ist folgendes ihr werdet gleich sehen das ist mega nice
es ist ein bisschen sowas wie dependa bot falls ihr dependa bot oder dependo dependa bot heißt das ding von github nur dass sie sich ein bisschen auf zusätzlich zu allen anderen sachen so ein bisschen auch auf kubernetes und jammelfeil und paketmanagement spezialisiert haben
wir haben in unserem repo noch nix großartig drinne wir haben nur ein jammelfeil was definiert das und das müsst ihr jetzt müsst ihr euch merken dass ihr seht was seht was das macht wir haben nur ein jammelfeil wenn wir das applyen auf unseren kubernetes cluster installiert das argo cd von dieser url sonst nix
man beachte das ref hier hinten dran ich habe da eine hardcoded versionsnummer ich hoffe die versionsnummer gab es sonst wird es jetzt gleich richtig funktionieren was ich was ich euch zeigen will 265 gab es 261 ja wahrscheinlich über text text text text 2.6.1
ja doch 2.6.1 gab es alles gut also man beachte hinten die die die die hardcoded version die ich da reingeschrieben habe so und wenn ich das ganz jetzt merche der sagt mir hier ok damit renovate funktioniert er hat auch schon detected dass ich hier
habe die erkennt muss ich eine renovate konfig bei mir ins repo pappen nämlich das da hey der ist ja richtig schlau man das ist cool normalerweise ist da nämlich nicht meine extended konfig drin sondern nur so eine basic konfig ich habe nämlich noch ein privates
repo wo ich ein paar secrets dafür hinterlegt habe dass ich nix aus versehen liege und so was der erkennt das automatisch nicht nicht nicht übel ok review changes ja wir haben das jetzt alles reviewed alles gut alles super reviewed und passt wunderbar
gemercht ich habe jetzt in meinem repo noch zusätzlich eine renovate jason liegen und was renovate jetzt macht ist folgendes ich gehe jetzt hätte es nicht eigentlich den issue aufmachen sollen
ach jetzt hat es den issue aufgemacht okay jetzt ist gut hat alles funktioniert so und was euch jetzt vielleicht auch fällt es gibt ein pull request nachdem ich hier diese renovate jason angelegt habe es gibt ein pull request und zwar hat renovate mein repo nach abhängigkeiten gescannt nach dem was ich benutze wie gesagt ist ein bisschen sowas wie die penderbot und zwar ist renovate aufgemacht
es ist mir aufgefallen dass ich in meinem kubanetes yaml file eine abhängigkeit drinne habe nämlich version 2.6.1 und renovate hat erkannt aktuell ist version 2.6.5 willst du nicht deine version updaten weil du was altes verwendest
es kann nervig sein wenn man beispielsweise zu doof war seine rpm äh seine rpm seine node modules richtig richtig aufzuräumen und erstmal 8000 pull requests bekommt aber ich finde für ein infrastruktur repo ist das wirklich praktisch weil du willst bei den meisten sachen zumindest mal einen hinweis drauf haben dass es eine neue version gibt und du überwachst es ja auch nicht ständig
den gibt es lokal den kannst du passt mal auf striker ist es viel besser ist viel besser du kannst renovate laufen lassen entweder als github app von denen hosted du kannst renovate laufen lassen als lokalen docker container als lokale cli du kannst auch installieren und lokalbar die einfach ausführen du kannst im kubanetes cluster laufen lassen und
du kannst es als github action laufen lassen und das ist eine sehr coole geschichte du kannst quasi nach jedem pull oder nach jedem nach jedem push kannst du das quasi über die github action den docker container davon ausführen der macht dann das gleiche also wenn du keinen bock hast diesen hosted service von denen zu verwenden kannst du das benutzen das finde ich ist eine sehr coole geschichte und der hat mich jetzt darauf hingewiesen guck mal da max also hier im dashboard steht alles was er gefunden hat
steht drin hier guck mal her max ich habe erkannt du verwendest in deinen config files
über gitlab kannst du es auch laufen lassen du verwendest in deinen config files und zwar hier verwendest du eine alte version der macht sogar die release notes rein guck mal du kannst sogar die release notes angucken an der stelle was er erkannt hat
bis darauf hast du auf einen blick alles drinne was du wissen musst zu dem aktuellen release und dann kannst du dich entscheiden willst du abcreateen oder nicht so jetzt sage ich merge pull request alles klar wunderbar und schon habe ich hier drinne die aktuellste version und er sagt gut gibt nichts weiteres mehr und das finde ich enorm praktisch das habe ich über den youtube video gefunden und das ding ist auch wirklich
beliebt renovate guck mal das hat das hat ordentlich viele sterne guck mal es hat 11.000 sterne mittlerweile ich kannte vorher nur die panda bot und ich muss sagen insgesamt finde ich renovate deutlich cooler als die panda bot weil es einfach mehr kann ich mein wer hat schon den parser dabei um so was hier hinten als version zu erkennen es ist ein kubanedas customized file mit einer hardcoded versionsnummer an der ende von der
url also dass er dass sie das erkennen als version und das abgleichen und die anbieten zu updaten ist wirklich eine sehr coole geschichte äußerst hock würde ich sagen ist das ganze ja so jetzt kommen zum thema argo cd den forward profil kann ich mir immer nicht merken wir können übrigens noch ein weiteres nice tool installieren nämlich k9s
das ist ein command line interface beziehungsweise konsolen klein für kubanedas ich weiß auch schwören manche leute drauf es ist ein bisschen netter als kubectl mein mit kubectl kannst du alles machen mit k9s kannst du nicht alles machen aber vieles hast du ein schönes command line gui für
also ich habe keine pots gestartet ok deswegen sieht man jetzt auch nichts drin ok das moment namespace all aha ich war im default namespace
ja man muss ein bisschen aufpassen es ist mega nice ja die können übrigens auch ich teile renovate supported languages die haben wirklich extrem viel extrem viel zeug drin also sie können ruby on rail gems npm package
ist und alles mögliche also dort net glaube können sie auch kannst ja sehr du kannst auch sehr viel konfigurieren und du kannst es selbst hausen wenn du nicht diesen service haben ich glaube du kannst sogar das frontend selbst posten ja also das ist wirklich cool das eigentlich dumme ist finde ich jetzt wenn man es übertreibt und zwar gerade frontend packages haben ja oftmals 50 milliarden abhängigkeiten und da wirst du ziemlich gespammt das ist gar nicht an sich das problem
wenn die leute das dann allerdings einzeln accepten über github hast du auf einmal deine gesamte githistorie voll mit merge dependency update ich will nicht sagen dass die info dass du eine dependency upgraded hast in deinem source code jetzt irgendwie oder deine npm konf oder so dass das unwichtig ist aber ganz ehrlich ich brauche nicht auf einen normalen commit 10
irgendwelche renovate commits deswegen finde ich ist es ganz sinnig wenn man das für ich habe es noch nicht benutzt für ein frontend projekt wenn man das für ein frontend projekt benutzt wo wirklich viele dependencies hat vielleicht sollte sich jemand die mühe machen und nicht wie ich gerade im github die pull requests durchklicken sondern vielleicht die pull requests auf der kommando zeile alle merchen und dann halt dass das irgendwie
ohne großartige merge commits und ein abschließendes irgendwie oder so was github auto merge dann hast du aber immer noch einen history eintrag
kann das sich einstellen dass du alle dependencies in einen commit also ob du das einstellen kannst dass er das alles in ein pull request macht weiß ich nicht da müsste er die alten irgendwie schließen oder so das passt nicht also du kannst es selbst machen ja das geht du kannst es
einfach für kommando zeile merchen zum beispiel alles nacheinander und dann nur einmal push muss halt immer gucken dass er keine keine merge commits die ganze zeit anlegt einmal pullen vorher und dann kannst du es alles merchen und dann kannst du es pushen
musste kannst du machen musste aber noch nicht mal wenn du wenn du gepullt hast und du hast den hast den aktuellen stand kannst du einfach merchen dann macht er ein fast forward merge ohne merge commit da brauchst du noch nicht mal in extra extra branche ja aber ist auf jeden fall sinnig und man sollte das machen wenn man wirklich viele dependencies im frontend projekt hat wo man nicht
zu gespammt werden will so also wir waren bei agocd also ich habe euch ja erzählt wir haben in git repo gemacht wo unsere git konf unsere klasse klasse konfig drinne ist und es soll jetzt ja so sein dass leute wir machen wir machen mal was wobei ich hab's jetzt ich hab's jetzt schon upgraded
wobei ihr werdet es ihr werdet es gleich sehen ihr werdet es gleich sehen ich habe nämlich noch nicht applied das ganze ich hoffe ich hab nicht auto apply auto apply drin glaub nicht oder
ich hab ja gar nichts drin ok ist gut ich habe noch gar nichts angelegt alles gut ich habe nicht mal cluster keys oder so registrieren man kann group anlegen ok das ist gut so wir machen jetzt support weiterleitung ich hab das über k9s noch nie gemacht shift f ok wir wollen uns weiterleiten auf agocd
ok war ich halt fort vorwärts von hand es ist auch über 1024 keine ahnung warum das nicht funktioniert
wie können sie einfach von hand machen hast du den ingress 9 zählt für den neuen miniklub klasse ja eigentlich schon aber den brauche ich nicht dafür mit port weiterleitung wollen wir das einfach mal so
funktioniert sofort also port 808 ist port 8080 ist anscheinend doch doch available so localhost port 8080 jetzt müssen wir noch das password rauskriegen accept accept agocd am start wir machen mal das ist gar nicht so flash bang wie man denkt war doch immer noch ziemlich flash bang wenn das ding sich zum ersten mal installiert
dann hat es ein default secret gesetzt für den admin user das muss man einmal auslesen und zwar get secrets agocd namespace agocd agocd initial admin secret das brauche man achso das da genau das da brauche man und das ist natürlich ein kubernetes secret
und wie wir ja alle wissen sind kubernetes secrets nicht wirklich secret weil jetzt passt mal auf wenn ich das jetzt base 64 die code dann sieht man da auf einmal ein password drinne also das ist auch base 64 wie gesagt kubernetes secrets heißen zwar secrets damit ist aber nicht gemeint dass die nicht lesbar sind die hätten sie auch passwörter nennen können es ist halt einfach ein passwörter
und was man oder zertifikat was man unter secret im cluster eintragen kann aber es heißt nicht dass die verschlüsselt sind das allerwichtigste zuerst settings appearance dark theme enable die wichtigste sache schon mal erledigt so normalerweise würde ich jetzt das ganze ding hier auch wir sehen ihr seht wir haben noch eine alte version normalerweise würde ich das ganze ding jetzt ja auch über
jammel files konfigurieren anstatt das hier übers web interface zu machen aber ich zeige euch das jetzt mal übers web interface als erstes müssen wir unseren unser repo hinzufügen ich habe das ehrlich gesagt einmal vor einer ganzen weile gemacht und bisher nur über jammel files wieder mal gucken ob ich das überhaupt noch sich selbst deployen lassen das wollte ich eigentlich für nächsten stream machen das wollte das wollte ich eigentlich für nächsten
stream machen dass das ding sich selbst updaten kann aber wir können wir können es auch
wir können es auch machen dann bräuchten wir allerdings hier irgendwie noch so was wie okay machen wir das mal dann bräuchten wir sowas wie apps und ich kann ich copy paste mir das mal von
apps von meinem anderen repo ergo cd alles klar muss ja muss ich aber ein bisschen muss ich aber ein bisschen anpassen so apps so new file ergo cd app definition ergibt ergibt hoffentlich gleich halbwegs sinn wenn man dann sieht wie es läuft
so das dumme dabei ist jetzt nur ich habe noch gar kein repo key hinter hinterlegt
willst du spick ich spicke die ganze zeit schon
ja das kenne ich das ist ganz cool weil das asynchron verschlüsselt mit einem im cluster generierten key ist ganz nice
ich bin in letzter zeit so ein bisschen auf external secrets hängen geblieben
nee ich bin in letzter zeit ein bisschen auf external secrets hängen geblieben da kannst du
nämlich beispielsweise azure key vault den google secret manager und den aws secret manager und alles mögliche dranhängen
und da deine secrets herziehen das sind sie das sind sich alle 15 sekunden oder sowas
dann brauchst du nämlich die secrets schlicht und ergreifend gar nicht einzuchecken in irgendwelche yaml files
aber du hast so ein bisschen ein hennei problem weil manchmal brauchst du ja auch initial
das eine oder andere so jetzt muss ich mal kurz überlegen wie ich das mache leute und zwar das problem ist
ich müsste jetzt ich müsste jetzt den repo key irgendwo hinterlegen
also ich weiß wie ich es machen kann das problem ich ich will euch ja ich will euch ja nicht immer
den screen screen pleck pleck machen ich weiß wie wir es machen wir fügen wir fügen einfach initial
mal ein secret ich weiß wie wir es machen wir fügen den secret hinzu
das passt schon wir fügen den secret wir fügen den secret hinzu
und
ja genau wir fügen wir fügen den secret hinzu
ich überlege gerade ob ich einen token habe
muss mal kurz gucken ob ich überhaupt einen token habe was da drauf zugreifen kann ja ist ein bisschen blöd
wartet mal lasst mich mal kurz gucken ob ich einen token habe was da drauf zugreifen kann ja ist ein bisschen blöd
token habe was da drauf zugreifen kann ja ist ein bisschen blöd wartet mal lasst mich mal kurz gucken
token das kann ich euch jetzt halt nicht on stream zeigen blöd personal access tokens
expires soon ja gut so soll mal expiren
repository access ok nice da kann ich die anderen auch hinzufügen alles klar sehr gut
nice gut dann habe ich dann habe ich einen token hier was ich verwenden kann alles gut
da muss ich euch jetzt tatsächlich noch mal kurz schwärzen und ich muss mein clipboard ausschalten
weil ansonsten kopiere ich jetzt mein password mein token das ist ein bisschen ein bisschen blöd
kurz kurz überlegen wo ich das mache
ist blöd wenn man das alles so umschiffen muss aber gut
ich muss ich muss repos minikube wir gehen jetzt einfach da rein start
so ok ich habe es gespeichert glaube ich glaube ihr könnt wieder ihr könnt wieder gucken
das werde ich einfach nicht pushen aber nicht dass das das token hat so gut wie das token hat so
gut wie keine rechte ich hoffe ich werde nichts ich werde nichts liegen liegen also ich habe hier
eine datei die sich nennt super geheimpunkt sh die sollte ich besser nicht öffnen ich mache jetzt
mal kurz start start sr script für meinen cluster weil so ein paar sachen brauche ich halt die
standardmäßig da sind normalerweise würde ich mir die auch aus einem secret manager holen
allerdings jetzt jetzt ist zu funktioniert es funktioniert sonst nicht richtig hier und streben
wir legen jetzt in dem start sr legen wir wenn wir initial den klassen hochfahren legen wir
einfach zwei namespaces an dass es dann da keine probleme mehr gibt und wir createn ein secret
einmal falsches tab und ripp ach nee excellent token github user github token gibt kein falsches tab
so github github user ist einfach github user ist wo bloß wobei das egal ist was man da reinschreibt
ok gut das sollte sollte hoffentlich jetzt reichen cmord plus x start.sh ja ja ok alles klar so secret
ist drin packt man das hatte ich das hatte ich heute eigentlich gar nicht vor jetzt jetzt war
komplizierter als das ganze sein muss ich habe euch an sich gezeigt was wir eigentlich genau
machen wie man es eigentlich benutzt und ich bastel jetzt irgendwelche sachen die bevor man
das gesehen hat eigentlich keinen sinn ergeben also irgendwie nicht so optimal aber was willst du
machen was willst du tun würde jetzt der echte gangster dazu sagen so also jetzt haben wir hier
die app angelegt wir sollten jetzt zugriff haben auf unser repo projekt projekt ist default
kennst du ein paar gute sources um sich mal also nebenbei macht man das nicht kubernetes selbst
so der reine kern ist gar nicht mal das problem aber das ist einfach ein fass ohne boden du musst
dich mit so viel trittanbieter sachen beschäftigen mit so viel abläufen mit
mit so vielen zusatz technologien wie generierte dann jammel pfeils wie bauste
deine manifest zusammen und alles mögliche bei welchem klaut anbieter machst du wie was
und so was ist ein fass ohne boden gute sources es gibt gute videos auf github zum lernen also
im deutschsprachigen bereich finde ich so mal als übersicht finde ich das video wirklich gut
ja das hier also wenn er irgendeiner sich mal zwei stunden kubanitas angucken will von jemand der
sich im vorfeld ein bisschen gedanken dazu gemacht hat nicht einfach stream startet wie ich und
aufgeht er macht wirklich aber auch nur die basics also der erklärt wie man labels anlegt
wie man jammel pfeils anlegt die pläute ein paar pots skaliert die glaube ich mal
rauf macht einen macht einen reverse proxy davor aber das kann ich wirklich empfehlen das video
link please hier siehst auch den titel leute warum warum wollte ok ich pass den link aber
meine titel suchen auf youtube kriegt man doch kriegt man auch gebacken so jetzt muss ich
bisschen magic machen weil eigentlich war das für diesen stream gar nicht geplant was ich
jetzt mache und zwar wir haben argocd deployed ihr habt noch keine ahnung was argocd ist das wollte
ich euch jetzt eigentlich zeigen aber der chat hat gesagt ich soll es richtig machen und zwar
dass ich das ganze selbst verwaltet ok aber was mit der musik los monka es das macht mich aber
fertig ja schon besser ich versuche jetzt so ein minimales sample zu basteln was funktioniert
so customize jetzt kommt jetzt kommt super krasse magic wo ihr nix versteht und ehrlich
ich auch nicht ich zeige es euch trotzdem gleich beim massive magic keine ahnung habe
ich auf github gefunden high IQ shit ist falsch ist falsch auch hier hin ne moment
ne das ist hier ist richtig richtig richtig high q shit so namespace haben war aber argocd selber
noch ja so das ingress lasse ich jetzt mal weg
wobei das lassen wir auch weg ok
jetzt muss ich überlegen dass ich nix vergesse ich hoffe dass ich hoffe das funktioniert so
also sieht das aus wenn ich stinger machen muss die ich eigentlich gar nicht vor hatte
eigentlich das repo sondern cute ok so wenn ich das jetzt richtig gemacht habe dann sollte
dann sollte sich das jetzt applyen lassen ich hoffe ich habe nix verkehrt gemacht
schau mal mal guck mal mal apply post jam post jam post jam wie das hat es einfach
funktioniert seriously hey das hat funktioniert war sie nicht gedacht aber der zugriff auf repo
funktioniert nicht oder repo jam geht nicht was infra ah moment moment ich hab's falsch
benannt bonkers ah projekt infra habe ich ja weggelassen hier default default projekt alles
gut jetzt ist jetzt sogar komplett abgekackt ja ja warum ist das ist das hier so wunderbar ok
er war warum authentication required habe ich doch gemacht na geil jetzt habe ich
chat ich hätte ich hätte nicht dinger machen soll ich heute überhaupt nicht vor
hat jetzt habe ich jetzt habe ich irgendwas verkackt warum geht das nicht github secret
github secret habe ich doch angelegt github secret oder habe ich nicht github secret angelegt
github secret doch habe ich angelegt im namespace na dann guckt man mal wo ans liegt
pots all namespaces agocd ist richtig github secret sieht eigentlich ok aus
wisst ihr was ich mache den klasser noch mal kurz aus und wieder an ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher ob
ich nicht im vorfeld irgendwie komisches zeug eingestellt habe ich mache den klasser noch mal
aus und noch mal an und dann dann gucken wir mal so und damit ich euch zeigen kann was agocd jetzt
eigentlich cooles macht mache ich die versionsnummer noch mal runter wir gehen wieder auf 261 runter
so hier es läuft kein kubernetes zeug mehr und wir führen jetzt mal mini cube start aus
mini cube das können wir eigentlich hier reinschreiben start.sh
mini cube start genau und dann applyen wir das ganze noch mal und ich hoffe dann funktioniert
sonst war das ja heute war das ja heute nix
auf starten so angelegt apply
oh was hat er für schmerzen oben warning was
ja ja das hat er jetzt erstellt ok gut jetzt sollten wir get pots sollten wir wieder unsere
agocd pots bekommen ok wunderbar das funktioniert ja alles gut
secret secret
muss man wieder raus auslesen
ok da ist das wie kriegen wir das jemand eine gute idee wie wir das hier rauskriegen
passwort man kann auch irgendwelche jason outputs hier machen das ist mir aber zu kompliziert
wenn man grab passwort hat an field 2 ok alles klar jetzt base base 64 decode
habe ich lehrzeichen drin oder zu viel view secret das kenne ich nicht das muss ich mir
mal aufschreiben das ist eine gute gute idee was hat er für schmerzen ok base 64 decode
alles klar hier haben wir das passwort forward port forward machen localhost 8080 admin passwort
save unknown was ich habe doch ein passwort hinterlegt man wo ist das problem habe ich
das habe ich den falschen key hinterlegt eigentlich den falschen key ich weiß was
ich ich weiß was ich verkehrt gemacht habe oder ich weiß was ich verkehrt gemacht habe
ich habe mein super ich habe doch hier mein super super geheimpunkt sh was wo ich nicht
reingucken darf was jetzt natürlich schön in der history drinne ist dass ich auf was ich reingucke
ich muss das noch sourcen super geheim super geheim punkt sh bin basch so start
ich bin jetzt total beschert
äh bin ich blind oder was
doch doch das macht einen unterschied wenn ich keinen punkt schlechter vormachen dann versucht
das global zu finden und ansonsten halt nicht ah so naja gut
ich hoffe der fährt es jetzt gleich noch mal alles hoch
ne ja ja allready exist allready exist weißt du was
die liet nicht man setzt mal richtig das habe ich das habe ich jetzt echt nicht gesehen mit dem
ok so jetzt aber apply
auf mini cube gib alles gib gas
so wenn ich jetzt richtig gemacht habe
ok das ist noch nicht gestartet das dauert kurz guck mal die putz fahne jetzt erst hoch
ich habe jetzt den klasse erst gestartet das dauert jetzt 20 20 sekunden
warte mal bis die pots ready sind wichtig ist der hier der agus server das ist da wo das
frontend club drauf läuft der muss ready sein so get secrets da ist es wunderbar genau das will
ich haben forward forward ich hoffe jetzt geht die verbindung zu meinem get repo sonst kriege ich
anfälle pass das not exist gut das ist ja ein anderes problem pass das not exist ja einmal
richtig machen wer schon nicht verkehrt ja pass das not exist pass agus cd das schon mal nicht
verkehrt das schon mal gut welcher welcher pass existet bitteschön nicht oder moment jetzt ich
glaube ich habe das einfach nie gepusht oder ja natürlich geht et minus a ok und und geht
kommet minus a minus m kacke also exakte best practice so wie man seine kommets immer benennt
geht push origin master
geht pull minus minus freebase an der einen datei sollte sich ja nichts geändert haben
ok dann nicht
ich will ich wollte ich ich wollte eigentlich nicht forsten muss ich auch nicht muss ich auch
nicht weil dann fehlt mir die renovate wir machen es jetzt das war das war schon ok das war schon ok
weil man kann es natürlich
jetzt versucht er den mörsch zu machen was wahrscheinlich auch nicht geht wir machen wir
machen es jetzt einfach so wie es sich gehört freebase scheiß drauf das hat einen doofen
fehler sagt er hier bärmlich juckt mich nicht einfach jetzt check out fertig ist jetzt haben
jetzt haben wir es einfach überschrieben mit dem aktuellen mit dem aktuellen master stand
kann man auch reingucken das auch soweit das ist der ganze ganze müll drinne den wir hier drin
haben wollen kann sagen get rebase minus minus continue ja kackel push bar kackel push
versioner absicht ich habe die ich habe die absichtlich wieder runter runter runter gestellt
eben dass ich das dass ich das zeigen kann wie sich das wie sich das selbst updated
gut ha es funktioniert leute guck mal vielleicht ist euch jetzt schon was
aufgefallen ich musste nichts an meinem cluster machen und hier sind auf einmal zwei apps
aufgeploppt einmal agro cd selbst und einmal einmal ein root eine root anwendung die root
anwendung dient dazu alle anderen anwendungen agro cd zu registrieren gibt es mehrere ansätze
wie man das ganze machen kann aber ich habe es jetzt halt so gemacht wie es gemacht habe
so und jetzt seht ihr man hat agro cd in agro cd und es hat sich im hintergrund selbst gesüngt
wie euch vielleicht aufgefallen ist weil ich habe nix geupdatet so jetzt sinken wir agro cd mal
weil er der meinung ist dass irgendwie die hälfte outdated ist ok soll mir recht sein so sinkt
hält sie alles klar so und was man jetzt daran sieht ist ich kann jetzt durch einen push in
meinem repo sachen in meinem cluster aktualisieren dadurch agro cd pullt mein git repo alle 15
sekunden agro kann sich auch selber update da muss man allerdings ein bisschen aufpassen
wenn man es kaputt macht ist blöd ich kann jetzt quasi mit einem config update in meinem git repo
also in dem hier wenn ich hier was wenn ich hier was reinpushe kann ich es updaten so und
agro cd selber ist ja noch auf version agro cd customise ist ja noch auf version 2.61 was man
je nachdem wie man es eingestellt hat hier auch sieht aber an der stelle an der stelle nicht aber
hier oben sieht man es agro cd ist noch auf 261 so und jetzt um das ganze mal zusammenzubringen
wenn ich jetzt ich mache den pull request hier den muss ich umbenennen sonst hat renovate kein
bock mehr kein bock drauf das noch mal zu machen check weh besser nahe für pull request das heißt
unser cluster läuft jetzt so vor sich hin und macht 30 millionen requests am tag auf meiner
vm lokal und ich war so beschäftigt mit geld zählen dass ich nicht mitbekommen habe dass
agro cd 265 rausgekommen ist ich meine ich bin ja immer noch auf 261 und wir wissen ja
allerwichtigste play singly fast und immer die neueste version deswegen möchte ich agro cd
deswegen will ich erstmal bescheid gesagt bekommen haben dass agro cd 265 raus ist und dann will ich
agro cd automatisch updaten lassen mit also sich selber automatisch updaten lassen so ich sag
jetzt meinem renovate bock noch mal er soll mein repo analysieren und irgendwann macht er das dann
auch man kann hier übrigens in das dashboard reingehen und gucken was er was er denn so macht und
wann er denn wann er denn gelaufen ist normalerweise dauert es nicht lang normalerweise
vielleicht eine minute oder so dann ist er am start über dieses master issue hier kann man
übrigens renovate steuern also man kann hier unten dann ein häkchen reinsetzen und dann habe
ich habe ich eben das häkchen überhaupt reingemacht man kann das häkchen rein machen und das triggert
über den webhook den bot dass der das der jetzt gefälligst mal laufen soll so und wenn der bot
läuft okay ist gelaufen dann hat er bot wieder festgestellt das hatten wir eben schon mal hat
er festgestellt max achtung achtung playsingly fast deine version ist outdated und zwar du kannst
updaten von agro cd 261 auf 265 dann sage ich ja zeigt mal her was was hat sich denn hier so ok
hier wird eine versionsnummer angepasst ok wunderbar das sieht gut aus das wird gemerched und das
allerwichtigste immer eine rakete das funktioniert das natürlich gar nicht vor allem wenn es
rust projekte sind muss unbedingt eine rakete drunter und so eine komische grabe dann wird
das ganze gemerched und jetzt passt mal auf ich merke das hier auf github und jetzt gucken wir
mal wie lang es dauert bis agro cd das mitbekommt konfirm
schauen wir mal
ich starte mal meinen timer
und wenn habe ich auto update überhaupt eingeschaltet ich hoffe ich hoffe doch
ah guck mal hier ach mist ich habe agro ok ich habe auto update nicht eingeschaltet für agro cd so
leute der zeigt mir jetzt an guck mal da es ist ein update da jetzt klicke ich auf sync
normalerweise hätte es jetzt automatisch gemacht klicke ich auf sync und nach nichts allzu langer
ah jetzt ok oder nicht allzu langer zeit werdet ihr feststellen habe ich gleich agro cd
265 am start ist wahrscheinlich schon fertig der forward ist ausgegangen ich habe noch ich
habe noch kein reverse proxy davor der port weiterleitung ist ausgegangen und ich habe
agro cd 265 am start das heißt ich musste nix von hand an meinem cluster machen wenn man das jetzt
richtig eingestellt hätte also wenn man den eingang hätte so dass man keine port weiterleitung
braucht und hätte ich automatischen sync eingeschaltet dann hätte ich das cluster
jetzt quasi komplett von alleine geupdatet nur mit dem merchandise pull requests da muss man
sich halt überlegen ob man das so in dieser tragweite haben will radian tracer muss man
sich dann wirklich überlegen gerade wenn agro cd sich selbst update ist vielleicht ein bisschen
fragwürdig weil dann macht man vielleicht auch was kaputt dann dann machen wir noch
mal ein reverse proxy davor auf die schnelle dass wir eben keine blöden
port weiterleitung mehr brauchen das werde jetzt werde ich mir auch mal copy pasten wie gesagt
eigentlich hatte ich überhaupt nicht vor das zu machen was ich jetzt mache aber ok und auch
ein ingress davor ich werde jetzt eine domain liegen die mir gehört kappa lull.com aber ihr
müsst euch keine hoffnung machen da läuft nichts drauf aber wir können das wir können das lokal
verwenden um paar kubernetes sachen auszuprobieren ich habe ich habe übrigens auch noch nichts für
zertifikate angelegt deswegen wird das jetzt wahrscheinlich gar nicht funktionieren mal aus
probieren mal gucken mal gucken so zumindest machen wir das doch jetzt mal ich pushe das mit
meinem tollen commit das wird am ende das wird am ende die hässlichste git konfig aller zeiten
also ich habe ich habe eben die datei geabdeckt ok guck mal mal rein wie lang es dauert
wobei nee es ist ich kann es beschleunigen ich klicke jetzt einfach drauf sondern sollte
jetzt der sollte jetzt gleich checken normalerweise sollte er es hoffe ich warum warum auch immer
dass nicht checkt ich sollte mitbekommen haben das ist jetzt ich mache eigentlich nur die
argo cd konfig über ein repo in argo cd ja kann man auch machen pro crepe progression was was
hat er was hat er für schmerzen war warum
habe ich an der falschen stelle angelegt oh ich depp es komplett an der falschen stelle
der hat es alles richtig gemacht aber da kommt es gar nicht hin es kommt da rein lull ok pushen
wir das ganze noch mal aktualisieren wir unsere repos zack wir werden feststellen hier ist es
wieder weg und hier ist es hoffentlich und hier ist es jetzt da gleich so sink also ich
würde auch argo cd nicht nicht unbedingt automatisch darüber updaten so ingress
total hängen geblieben wo ist er denn da ist er doch also ich hätte ich suchen müssen ok
passt jetzt schauen wir mal ob das funktioniert ping argo cd punkt kappa lull punkt komm ok
ip löst schon mal auf körl es kann durchaus sein dass es nicht funktioniert
klar dass es irgendwie nicht nicht nicht tut
warum eigentlich nicht
get ingress
ingress ne engine x
das ist schon mal ok was macht eigentlich der der engine x moment ach ich habe mein ingress
gar nicht aktiviert add-on ja das ist halt da kann es auch funktionieren ingress ist quasi
ein reverse proxy oder einen proxy am eingang so körn mal gucken ob das jetzt nachträglich
geht hey rtt ps ja minus k hey es funktioniert guck mal argo cd punkt kappa lull punkt komm
das immer admin schon haben wir eine gültige gültige domain also gültig an anführungsstrichen
das ist immer noch ein selbst sein zertifikat weil ich noch kein letztes kript eingeboten
bringt die musik ist gerade ein bisschen sehr sehr energisch
hoffe das ist das richtige
ein secret ok das ist das richtige
ich habe übrigens mal nicht dass ich auch passwörter liege leute ich bin mir nicht
ganz sicher
ich liege keine passwörter alles gut man weiß ja nie
ok gut so und schon haben wir eine domain mit einem zertifikat was man jetzt auch theoretisch
über letztes kript machen könnte aber das mache ich heute nicht weil da habe ich nix
nix an keys da da müsste ich erst mal wieder was generieren was funktioniert so also wir
haben jetzt ein kubernetes cluster und ein git repo und was ich in dieses git repo rein
packen das machen wir heute nicht weil ich dieses git repo rein packen wird automatisch
deployed so nachdem ich jetzt ganz viel gemacht habe was ich eigentlich gar nicht machen
wollte was vielleicht aber fürs setup hier auch gar nicht so verkehrt ist jetzt deployen
wir mal eine app weil das ist ja letztendlich das was man machen möchte man will ja auf
seinem kubernetes cluster was laufen lassen man möchte ja nicht sich selbst verwalten
und sich dabei erst freuen dass sich schön selbst verwaltet sondern möchte ja auch
irgendwas darauf deployen was dann läuft also irgendwas was hello world für unseren fall
oder sowas jetzt zurück gibt ja gut laut lautechno tim schon der hat ja auch seine
drei kubernetes cluster daheim auf den faktisch so gut wie nix läuft wenn man da spaß dran
hat zum lernen ok why not kann man auch lokal in der vm basteln aber jeder wie er will ich
finde es teilweise ein bisschen übertrieben wenn man infrastruktur hat nur um sich selbst
zu verwalten aber aber ok jeder jeder wie er mag jetzt haben wir hier unsere unsere
config für unseren kubernetes cluster und jetzt bauen wir mal eine app
fife hat ab cute ab die cute ab bauen wir jetzt so da gehen wir nämlich in ein anderes
fenster und machen dort drinnen mal ein dotnet projekt und zwar eine web anwendung die hello
world zurück gibt und sonst nix quasi das was wir das letzte mal auch schon gemacht haben nur
mit ein paar kleinen anpassungen drin welchen clipboard manager verwendest du ich benutze
rofi zum suchen und clipboard manager ist cream clip glaube ich dort net in linux klar dort net
ist super mittlerweile unter linux ist eines der besten plattformen die es gibt nicht nur
für linux für alles nix kopium das ist so es ist nicht weil ich das so will sondern es ist so
neu webapp wir beschleunigen das ganze wir machen ja heute kein dotnet progas progas stream deswegen
machen wir das jetzt mal ganz zackig wo läuft das renovate ich benutze die github app du kannst
es allerdings auch selber hosten oder das kommando zeilen tool verwenden oder in docker container
verwenden oder dann kombiniertes klasse laufen lassen oder dass bei ihnen gehostet verwenden
gibt irgendwie alle möglichen varianten für jeden was dabei ok also die app kopiere ich uns
jetzt rüber vom letzten mal wie gesagt wir müssen heute wir müssen heute kein großartiges dotnet
progas progas zeug machen die app wird äußerst simpel die macht nämlich nix weiter außer kopier
das jetzt rüber was ok trust wir trusten alles alles getrusted hier programm cs folgendes
so jetzt ich kann die clipboard manager wieder anmachen dass ich was kopieren kann
so also unsere app macht nix weiter außer health checks zu haben unter slash health und über
der environment variablen name einzulesen um dann cute chatter rauszuhauen über index web request
sonst nix das war es mehr mehr werden wir daran mehr werden wir daran auch nicht bauen jetzt also
im prinzipie nicht weiter nicht mal groß aufmachen müssen wie gesagt ist ja wird er kein wird er
kein dotnet dotnet bastel stream heute was wir jetzt noch machen wir legen den dockerfile an
weil wir möchten ja das ganze in github pushen und mit github actions wir machen auch ein bisschen
github actions klein und über github actions den container bauen und in die github container
registry pushen ja so sieht es aus so dazu brauchen wir ein dockerfile um den um den
container zu bauen und nachdem wir jetzt nicht erst mal wieder fünf stunden nachgucken müssen
oder nachgucken wollen wie die richtige syntax ist kopiere ich mir den dockerfile es ist das
standard dotnet oder ein bisschen von mir leicht angepasstes standard dotnet dockerfile also
sprich wir nehmen das normale den normalen base container von microsoft den die gebaut haben
für ihre aktuelle dotnet version bauen das projekt im release modus kopieren es rüber
und am ende wird es gestartet fertig aus das ist alles also wenn ich jetzt docker bild mache dann
funktioniert das docker bild mache dann funktioniert das einfach wobei wenn ich docker bild machen wir
wir bauen das ganze jetzt über github action aber ich wollte euch bloß zeigen dass das dass
das funktioniert so mehr brauchen wir an der stelle eigentlich nicht wir können jetzt in
github gehen also ne pushen pushen sollten wir es vielleicht noch status ah sekunde wir brauchen
ein github ignore file für dotnet ansonsten wird ich push ja keine binaries hier hoch wim.github ignore
zack rein damit github status das sieht schon besser aus github ignore dockerfile programm
properties ok alles was wir haben wollen commit also git add einmal initial git commit minus
a minus m cute chat ajaja git push origin master triggert weil master verwendet wird
bitte nicht auf twitter posten so f5 da sind wir hier ist unsere app am start so und jetzt also
mein plan ist folgender ich will die app über github actions bauen in die github container
registry pushen und dann für unseren kubernetes cluster eine neue app anlegen also besser gesagt
ein neues deploy also neue app und ein neues deployment anlegen wo die app dann deployed
wird auf unseren kubernetes cluster
gucken wir mal hin gucken wir mal ob wir das hinkriegen einziges wo ich mir ein bisschen
probleme vorstelle ist access auf die container registry dafür brauche ich einen extra key
es wird doch zeit dass wir das nächste mal uns in den secret management lösungen überlegen
und uns angucken weil die gefahr dass ich bei irgendwas liege steigt ja image einfach
machen das ist eine gute idee das machen wir jetzt auch einfach ich mache das einfach
öffentlich die app weil hier ist ja nix hier ist ja nix irgendwie großartig secret secret
drinne ich kann das einfach öffentlich machen das ist richtig ganz einfach easy da muss ich
die projekt settings ich weiß nicht ob man da was sieht was ihr nicht sehen darf sehen dürft
wo macht man das überhaupt
wo macht man das ich glaube ich habe noch nie ein privates repo public gemacht das ist
separat vom git repo es ist egal machen wir machen das wo ist denn das
jetzt bin ich ok ich mache mich mal wieder an bin ich verwirrt wie macht man ein privates repo
ah change visibility change to public ok
yes
anyone can fork your repository is ok yes yes yes yes ok make public
wunderbar alles klar so jetzt unser repo public jetzt haben wir da auch kein problem
also wir müssen jetzt für github actions dass wir den container bauen können müssen wir
eine datei anlegen in einem ordner github workflows das ist so ich glaube sogar dass
sie da mittlerweile eine hilfe dafür haben wenn man nämlich auf actions geht pull request wir
konfigurieren kein renovate jetzt wenn man auf actions geht und dann kann man hat das nicht
so was wie empty auch egal dann legen wir jetzt einfach configure an egal wir kopieren ich
kopiere eh meine eigene meine eigene meine eigene github action rein gucken dass da keine
secrets drin sind man sollte keine secrets in github action schreiben aber vielleicht man weiß
ja nicht also was die action macht ist folgendes wenn text gepusht werden also sprich wenn eine
neue version gepusht wird dann macht ihn docker login docker login ist ein bisschen bisschen
bescheuerte bezeichnung für identifizieren gegenüber einer container registry oder benutzt
nicht etwa doch er kommt docker hub sondern er benutzt die github github container registry
und dann baut er den container und dann pusht er den container nicht zur test app sondern zu
cute app das könnte man übrigens auch noch schöner machen dass man das gar nicht reinschreiben muss
gibt es ein paar ansätze wie man wie man so eine action bauen kann
so und jetzt speicher ich das ganze und wenn ich glück habe funktioniert alles
ja docker image punkt jammel vollkommen ok so geben wir mal unser repo rein holen noch mal
ok er erkannt und jetzt machen wir github tag 1 0 punkt oder v 0.0.1
das gleiche noch mal github push minus minus tags und wenn ich das gemacht habe jetzt sollte
er eigentlich eine github action laufen macht er auch es läuft eine github action die unser
container image baut und unsere in die public github container registry pusht was nicht
funktioniert hat weil weil invalid tag repository must be lowercase ok das wusste ich nicht wie
heißt wie heißt mein repository dann publish published your package einfach alles klein
geschrieben dann cute app wahrscheinlich alles klein geschrieben das wusste ich gar nicht
dass das so nicht funktioniert ok dann schreiben wir hier einfach rein cute app ich hoffe das
funktioniert dann immer noch warum habe ich jetzt warum habe ich jetzt auf lief gedrückt richtig
brain dead ok rerun den ein gibt ja nur ein ach nee das funktioniert ja nicht weil zu dem
zeitpunkt das noch verkehrt war muss ich muss ich noch mal neu tag pull tag version 2 ganz
ganz essentiell ja ich funktioniert hat er wieder hat er wieder das gleiche was be lowercase push
minus minus tags so aber jetzt jetzt sollte es funktionieren
so gucken wir mal ob der das container image jetzt baut bild
github please die anzeige ist ein bisschen pepega an der stelle aber so ist es halt
jetzt können wir nur präge machen chat einmal präge weil wir müssen runde wir müssen runde
präge machen dass das funktioniert sonst klappt das nicht wenn es sich pusht nickt es an euch
verbinden ok public repo nicht gleich public container registry moment public container
warum habe ich keine rechte da rein zu pushten
warum wo ist das problem jetzt
warum habe ich keine rechte in meine eigene container registry zu pushen
ich weiß woran das liegt das ist immer so das ist immer so das ist dann das ist richtig
hängen geblieben gemacht da muss man immer hier irgendwo was einstellen jaja ich erinnere mich
genau workflow permissions ich glaube ja das muss man glaube ich machen das ist richtig
hängen geblieben fragt mich fragt mich nicht was warum na gut ist vielleicht ganz ok dass
es standardmäßig nicht geht kann man nicht einfach sagen rerun den hier na gut es ist ja
nur das hier und der glück haben geht jetzt irgendwann mal unser container image drei
stunden später eventuell es liegt auch an euch ihr habt kein präge gespams ohne präge
kein container push ganz einfach jetzt ok jetzt für jetzt wird es funktionieren easy
pushing easy hat funktioniert sisse kaum ist der präge im chat am start schon funktioniert so wir
haben ein container image generiert und zwar nein max klickt doch nicht immer so ein scheiß an
cute ab wir haben ein container image übrigens kann sich jeder bei euch jetzt das container
image pullen ihr habt nichts davon weil dem container image eigentlich nichts spannendes
drin ist aber ihr könntet ihr könntet ein container image erstellen davon ableiten und
eine eigene hello world ab bauen macht macht macht keinen sinn sich das zu pullen aber gut
jetzt habe ich meine app erstellt hat meine app gebaut über github actions und jetzt will ich
meine app ja laufen lassen über beziehungsweise in meinem kubernetes cluster oder in meinem
das heißt wir machen da bin ich mir jetzt gar nicht sicher aus dem kopf wie man es
gescheit macht ja so zumindest wir legen in apps schon mal eine neue app an und zwar new file
cute app punkt jammel und füllen das hier mal aus also cool geht ab cute cute app
ne moment was mache ich denn blödsinn blödsinn schwachsinn blödsinn ist alles richtig wie es da
drin steht da fack ist alles richtig wie es da drin steht das repo ist ja immer noch das gleiche so
meta data agocd ist schon mal falsch cute app ist das richtige namespace default machen wir die
mal rein ist egal ein moment der falsche namespace hier default namespace path cute app dann legen
wir unten ein ordner an für die cute app und da kommen jetzt unsere manifests rein wie das ganze
deployed werden soll glücklicherweise habe ich mein deployment noch vom letzten mal am start
repos minicube code leider nicht super geheim nur cute punkt jammel öffnen und da kopieren
wir unser deployment jetzt einfach mal rüber new file mehr brauchen wir da nicht zack so passt
das noch was ich das letzte mal hier gebaut habe deployment replicas 6 ja unbedingt wichtig die cute
app muss zwingend ganz wichtig mindestens sechs container laufen haben sonst ist er nicht hoch
verfügbar genug matching labels cute labels ich hoffe mal das stimmt alles ja localhost nein das
image ist jetzt anders das image ist jetzt das von meiner container registry resource limit
container port 80 health port 80 alles gut passt service load balancer können wir uns eigentlich
schenken brauchen wir an der stelle nicht weil wir machen ihnen ingress davor also den proxy
und nee der host wird nicht kackel.kekwe.services sondern cuteapp.kappalull.com und ich hoffe dass
mein ingress auch port 80 macht und nicht nur 443 so ich habe bestimmt irgendwas meine jammel
engineer skills sind nicht on point ich habe bestimmt hier irgendwie namespace falsch oder
irgendwas habe ich hier bestimmt nicht richtig nicht richtig gemacht gut es steht gar kein
namespace drin das heißt namespace sollte die fault sein hoffe ich mal schauen wir mal
gucken wir mal was funktioniert zumindest kann ich euch jetzt noch mal den vorteil von argocd zeigen
ich mache nichts an meinem kubernetes cluster leute das ist jetzt ja das coole daran ich mache
nichts an meinem kubernetes cluster ich gehe einfach nur in mein in mein repo rein commit die
config ah ihr habt neues kackel so commit die config für meine neue app warte bis argocd
refreshed hat oder lass ihn refreshen autosync und zack ist die cuteapp am start ist das nicht
nice aber die cuteapp ist noch nicht deployed weil ich nicht automatisch die deployment für
die cuteapp eingestellt habe cuteapp is missing autosync okay er würde anlegen einen service
ein deployment also die für die pots und ein ingress eingang also sinken wir das ganze mal
und ich hoffe ich habe jetzt alles richtig gemacht wahrscheinlich nicht sechs pots starten aber
wahrscheinlich geht das pull nicht oder sowas error crash ja gut irgendwas habe ich verkackt
vom prinzip hat schon mal funktioniert er hat sechs pots angelegt die nicht funktioniert
warum warum crashen die dann gucken wir doch mal warum die crashen wir mal get lock
pot cuteapp warum crashst du was
mein app hat einen bug hat einen bug
doch kein bild habe ich irgendwas verkackt wir testen mal lokal ob die app läuft
docker run wait a minute
ich weiß woran es liegt
oh man mein startfile heißt nicht cuteapp heißt das ding ja nicht testapp
falscher aber man die fehlermeldung von von totnet ist ja mal wieder excellent oder
niemand niemand checkt was uns doch net damit sagen will
ran gucken wir mal ob es prinzipiell funktioniert
ja funktioniert ok wir probieren es mal aus lokal host pot mal karl lokal host slash health
ach so ich habe keine container keine ports weiter klar ist egal ist egal ich kann das update
zeigen mache ich auch aber wir passen noch was anderes an und zwar wir gehen in unsere app
konfiguration und sagen jetzt agocd wie heißt das automated irgendwas automated sync policy
dass ihr seht dass es sich komplett automatisch fix automated sync policy speck automated
wir wollen haben allow empty ist ok das darf es ruhig sein was haben wir noch sehr viel
eigentlich brauchen wir da nichts von automated ist gut gut so jetzt haben wir unsere
ich überlege grad wie ist denn der effekt jetzt am besten ich push das hier zuerst weil weil weil
ich zeige euch auch warum passt mal auf das ist jetzt richtig es ist richtig cool was wir gebaut
haben und euch wird auch gleich auffallen warum so erstmal ich lasse ihn noch mal kurz aktualisieren
hier jetzt jetzt jetzt sieht man nämlich wie gut das wie gut das in kombination passt ja ja
refresh refresh alles klar refresh refresh hat er hat das jetzt gecheckt hat das jetzt gecheckt
das auto auto refresh alles nee warum nicht warum hat er nicht gecheckt das autorefresh alles
ich habe sync policy auf automated gestellt warum hat er das nicht kapiert
wo ist das problem wahrscheinlich weil er immer noch processing ist kann das sein
warum ist warum warum ist sync nicht nicht drin ok ich delete das jetzt einfach mal
du hast die endung am docker fall gepusht ja wenn man zu viel zeug offen hat ok ja das
hätte ich mir auch sparen können aber gut wenn man auch so schöne comment messages macht dann
blickt man ja auch richtig gut durch ok jetzt jetzt hat er es gecheckt ok refresh
und jetzt hat er automatisch gesüngt guckt jetzt hat er automatisch die pot sind immer
noch kaputt und jetzt und jetzt seht ihr gleich was sehr cool ist was super agile 5 hat bis sehr
def win ob es ist also nur nur die ganz frei fertigen können das so es ist jetzt sind status
ist kaputt die pots sind immer noch kaputt alles gut ja weil wie gesagt die ich habe
nicht noch nicht die neueste version deployed ab details kurz gucken autosync ist an gut und
jetzt habe ich den back gefixt ihr habt ja gesehen ich hatte einen back im docker fall also sprich
die app wurde falsch falsch gebaut so was wir jetzt machen und wo der effekt eigentlich richtig
richtig nice ist ich setze zu neuen tag nämlich tag 0.3 dann pushe ich das ganze und alleine wird
übrigens noch nix passieren aber jetzt könnt ihr den sehr schönen effekt sehen ja habe ich ich
habe statisch reingeschrieben aber jetzt kommt jetzt kommt alles zusammen was ich euch was ich
euch zeigen wollte ich habe eine neue container also wir warten jetzt erst mal bis es gebaut ist
ich glaube ich muss die config noch anpassen aber ich zeige trotzdem so wir warten mal bis
unsere bis unsere action durch ist keckel eindeutig beste beste bezeichnung dafür
keck keck keck keck keck keck keck keck
du du du du du du du du du du du du du du douthil
wir müssen noch eine sache anpassen mache ich jetzt auf screen dass der dass der effekt
nicer ist bei scheiß drauf ich mache das nicht auf screen kannst du ihr könnt ruhig sehen
pass jetzt noch mal kurz meine renovate jason an weil ich da was vergessen hab drin sollte
das eigentlich so aussehen als match aber das überhaupt von netas jammel soll er auf
jeden fall untersuchen so und jetzt kommt der prog moment hat meine app gepusht app
wurde gebaut und jetzt läuft irgendwann mein bot im hintergrund gucken ob er gucken ob er
gelaufen ist und dann wird euch was auffallen was mein bot festgestellt hat und zwar hat mein bot
festgestellt irgendwann wenn er gelaufen ist wie gesagt haustet kostenloser service da kann
nur mal durchaus ein paar sekunden dauern oder habe ich eben nicht geklickt
habe ich leute jetzt ok ist gelaufen und guckt mal da da ist ein pull request und was ist in
diesem pull request drinne guck mal da es gibt ein update für cute app version 003 keine change log
informationen und siehe da er möchte meine app update von 2 auf version 3 und dann sage ich jetzt
ok gut will ich machen also ihr müsst jetzt mal an der stelle muss ich muss ich jetzt muss jetzt also
ihr müsst jetzt an der stelle realisieren dass das hier sehr vereinfacht ist und ich alles in
einer person mache normalerweise hätte ja nicht ich die anwendung gebaut sondern irgendein
programmierer oder irgendein frag mich nicht 5 hat sprint super krass mega koordinator ist
der meinung jetzt gibt es eine neue version und pusht das dann also habe ich ja nichts mit zu tun
also ich habe jetzt alles zwar selbst gemacht habe ich ja nichts mit zu tun und ich bekomme
jetzt eine nachricht in meinem kubernetes konfigurier pro guck mal es gibt eine neue
version von einem unserer selbst entwickelten programme please lasst doch mal updaten da sage
ich einfach jawohl ich möchte den pull request und sobald das drinne ist passt mal auf was jetzt
passiert ich hoffe das funktioniert jetzt weil es könnte durchaus sein dass es nicht geht
weil es noch progressing ist wenn ich muss ich einmal von hand anstoßen
so anscheinend aus irgendwelchen gründen funkt jetzt nicht zink
es hat schon leute es ging einfach zu schnell ich hätte überhaupt nichts machen es ging
einfach zu schnell es war so schnell dass ich gar nicht mitbekommen habe es ging einfach guck mal
meine pots sind da es hat funktioniert was auf und meine pots laufen cute app am start und wenn
der ingress funktioniert dann kann ich jetzt sogar sagen cuteapp.kappa0.com und jetzt ist das mit dem
deployen neuer apps wirklich easy geworden app eintracht anlegen gibbi
das hatten wir heute schon offen k9s
um das jetzt noch mal zu recapitulieren wir haben unseren container gefixt haben
neuen tag gepusht also die app war kaputt so wir haben die app lokal gefixt haben das gepusht
dann lief eine github action die bei jedem tag push läuft also wir haben das neu getagged die
die neue software version die den bug behoben hat die github action hat erkannt aha es gibt
neuen tag lasst mal ein image bauen hat ein image gebaut hier mit dieser action
blablabla image gebaut das image seht ihr auch hier
daraufhin hat mein bot der meine repos überwacht festgestellt also mein kubernetes config repo
festgestellt es gibt eine neue version von unserer app das hat er festgestellt nachdem
das hier gelaufen ist nachdem das image gebaut wurde dann habe ich das gemercht und quasi
zehn sekunden später ohne mein zutun wie gesagt ich hätte nicht klicken müssen das war es war
schon fertig und falsches falsches fenster ohne mein zutun ist jetzt auf einmal die app
hat sich automatisch synchronisiert neu deployed bug ist behoben pots laufen wieder das heißt wenn
ich jetzt bug hab muss ich gar nichts machen ich fix das ich pusht das und entweder ist es so
eingestellt dass ich das hier automatisch merche oder möglichst schnell das das ganze
merkt und sobald ich gemercht hat mit meinem config repo ist es da man könnte sich jetzt zum
beispiel auch dafür entscheiden dass man das hier die config für die app gar nicht in dem
repo hat sondern auch im app repo so für das ja das ist ein bisschen handhabungsfrage manche
sagen sogar man sollte das noch weiter aufsplitten quasi so einen cluster config repo ein config
repo pro app und ein app repo für die software an sich philosophie frage und wahrscheinlich
auch eine frage dessen wie viele leute arbeiten dran wie groß und umfangreich ist das ganze
und das ist das ist halt wirklich wirklich nice ja ich zeige euch ich zeige euch das ganze jetzt
noch mal fusion ich gucke mir gleich an was du geschrieben hast ich zeige euch das ganze noch
mal noch noch mal weil es wirklich ein cooler workflow ist so wir sollen ein neues feature in
unsere app einbauen und zwar unsere app soll jetzt anstatt cute chatter nur noch cute chat
erscheinen messer besser bester feature request aller zeiten so machen wir neues
machen wir neues kommet nennen das sogar mal hier best feature ever pushen das ganze dann
setzen wir neuen tag wie gesagt das kann man alles wenn man möchte automatisieren aber an
der stelle ich finde es nicht schlecht wenn man so so eine losschick action noch von hand macht
hatte ich so machen wir neuen tag wir können auch sagen gibt push origin minus minus tags also ich
habe neues feature eingebaut ich habe das ganze ich habe das ganze gepusht ich setze jetzt ein
neues tag drauf weil ich sage jawoll dass es neue version die ich releasen will und dann schicke ich
das ganze ab und in der zwischenzeit gucke ich jetzt mal gucke ich jetzt mal im chat rein was
was es für questions gegeben hat so also wir haben momentan ein hartes problem dass wir
fehler bei notes haben und wir nicht wissen woran das liegt viele haben den status not ready ok
die logs frustrieren uns weil wir nix finden einer von unseren hat mittlerweile überschritten
hey ich weiß das ist das was euch nicht unmittelbar was bringt aber denkt mal
über englern haustät beziehungsweise managet kubernetes nach einfach nur für den fall der
fälle oder habt ihr schon kann natürlich auch sein also managet heißt ja je nach anbieter
unterschiedlich unterschiedlich stark managt eigentlich nix zu sagen keine ahnung
hast du deine load balancer drin ein so bei mir jetzt oder oder meister fusion ich habe
einen inkraten engine x ingress am anfang am eingang dass das funktioniert wie hast du
installiert nee ich habe agos ich verwalte agocd über agocd rancher ich sehe auch aktuell kein
einsatzgrund zu wirklich bei mir auf der arbeit verwenden wir managet kubernetes ich weiß man
kann den renter glaube ich auch irgendwelche remote cluster einbinden aber dann weiß ich
wie sie nicht das ist hauptsächlich kubernetes bei meiner neuen arbeit sein hauptsächlich google
renter hätte ich jetzt eher sowas gesehen im rahmen von ich will wirklich was selbst betreiben
ansonsten verspüre ich da nicht den zug dazu mir rancher anzugucken ich weiß es gibt rancher
desktop noch so als docker ersatz so unser bot hat hoffentlich jetzt schon was erkannt
nicht warum nicht warum hat er bot nicht erkannt dass es eine neue image version gibt
wahrscheinlich weil er bot noch gar nicht gelaufen ist ok nice müssen wir vielleicht
mal einstellen vor zwei minuten ist er gelaufen was ist da los bot warum hast du die neue
image version nicht erkannt anzeige ist raus was was was geht da aber vor zwei minuten war
vielleicht das package noch nicht fertig gebildet könnte das sein wäre dies wäre dies möglich
auf so hä jetzt wollte ich zeigen wie cool das funktioniert habe ich bin ich jetzt total
hängen geblieben habe ich was kaputt gemacht habe ich irgendwas verkackt oder warum erkennt
er warum erkennt er die neue die neue app version nicht mehr 004 er erkennt doch dass das da ist
ja bot bot irgendwie am verkacken gerade keine ahnung eben hat genau das gleiche noch funktioniert
das verstehe ich nicht warum hat mein bot nicht gecheckt dass ich eine neue dependency
abgedatet habe so dann mache ich das jetzt einfach eine hand scheiß drauf
moment sollt ich sollte mal kurz holen
trage ich halt mal von hand ein sammer sehr merkwürdig habe ich hatte hat er irgendwie
mit ein docker pull ne ist alles da ok kein plan warum der das jetzt nicht gecheckt hat das
natürlich doof wenn das manchmal nicht geht vielleicht ist es auch gerade überlastet oder
er müsste eigentlich kapieren dass das eine neue version da ist hat er vielleicht probleme weil
ich schon ein ticket habe was so heißt ok gucken wir mal rein gucken wir mal gucken wir mal rein
warum das warum er der meinung ist dass das nicht zum glück zum glück extra hier alle tokens aus
ok top es sieht man sieht man glücklicherweise nicht da gar aus
ach leute ich weiß ok jetzt habe ich echt keinen plan woran es liegt warum er das nicht erkannt
hat also normalerweise müsste das erkennen wir haben eine neue version am start keine ahnung ich
vielleicht könnte das ein bug in dem könnte es ein bug sein benennen wir mal den pull request um
dass er nicht mehr erkennt dass er dass er das schon mal gescannt hat oder beanstandet hat
er sehr merkwürdig few seconds ago
ok jetzt habe ich keinen plan vielleicht vielleicht ist er bot gerade irgendwie
vor zwei minuten hat es noch funktioniert mit dem anderen pull request keine ahnung warum das
jetzt nicht geht also normalerweise sollte jetzt erkennt es gibt version version 4 aber na gut so
dann pushen wir das ganze mal von hand um das einmal abzuschließen für heute
ne ne ne best best feature ever gepusht so agocd zack sollte jetzt wenn er deployed hat
komm mal hier zack zack zack wenn er deployed hat sollte dann irgendwann hier gucken wir uns das
ganze mal an wenn das nicht funktioniert habe ich was anderes verkackt da sollte dann irgendwann
gleich cute cute chat anstatt cute chatter stehen an das autodeploy
meine pots werden gerade neu gestartet seht ihr manche sind manche fertig rolling update leute
hier rolling update jetzt sieht man es gerade live manchmal lande ich noch auf alt manchmal
noch auf neu hat funktioniert guckt zack neue app neue app version deployed ohne ausfall dazwischen
easy das cool oder man hätte man hätte eben natürlich mal gucken können wie die pots wie
sich die pots neu starten das wäre da ist gewesen zu sehen was ich mache ich habe eine
neue app version deployed die jetzt cute chat anstatt cute chatter anzeigt um zu sehen dass
es ohne ausfall geht und dass sich komplett automatisch aktualisiert aber präserie für
dich ich zeige es dir noch mal guck mal das mit dem bot lassen wir jetzt mal weg guck mal
ich habe eine app gebaut also ich habe lokalen kumpane des klaster laufen ich habe eine app
gebaut die sinnloses zeug ausgibt cute chat 123 wir möchten unbedingt dass der status hier cute
123 chat ist so best feature ever committen wir jetzt pushen das setzten wir einen tag drauf
und zwar tag 0.5 dann wird der tag gepusht dann läuft eine github action los wenn der tag gepusht
wurde und erzeugt ein neues docker image pusht dieses docker image in die github container
registry normalerweise habe ich den bot laufen der jetzt erkennt dass ich eine
neue version habe aber das beschleunigen wir jetzt mal den bot image pusht das in
die container registry irgendwann nach drei stunden wenn das in der neuen container registry
angekommen ist kann ich meine kumpane des config aktualisieren und zwar haben wir jetzt version
5 dann pushe ich meine kumpane des config und dann gucken wir mal uns die pots an und du wirst
sehen in ein paar sekunden fängt der ganze cluster automatisch an die pots neu zu starten
und ich habe keinen ausfall des services
der macht jetzt rolling update da bin ich schon auf neuen pot gelandet ist das eine
art deployment pipeline automatisierung ja schau es dir in k9s an ok weil ihr seid
hier sieht man es genau hier sieht man es guck wie die ganzen pots neu gestartet jetzt
sind alle durch jetzt wurden alle neu gestartet siehst du hier age von den pots und ich habe
die neue app version da und das ist schon sehr nice oder muss man mal ehrlich sagen neue app
version gepusht kumpane des manifest angepasst automatischer rollout ohne unterbrechung
was ist das das hat schon was also im vergleich zu klassischem wir setzen uns um ein Uhr nachts
hin upgraden irgendwas und konfigurieren noch dinger um und vielleicht erzeugen wir noch
neue vms und sowas ist das hier schon deutlich cooler gut ich gebe zu das ist ein sehr simples
beispiel mit einer komplett stateless app die nirgends wohin zugreift und keine datenbank hat
und sowas natürlich ist das in der freie wildbahn dann auch ein bisschen komplizierter und
anspruchsvoller aber so vom ansatz her ist das mega nice du pusht deine app du guckst noch
einmal drauf indem du deine neue app version in ein kumpane des manifest einträgst und dann wird
das ganze gepusht und gibbi der klasse rollt automatisch aus ohne dass es unterbrechung gibt
milchmann dankeschön für den sub
milchmann dankeschön für den sub radian tracer danke für den sub don't cry so
wenn sub supreme ist supreme atino skill killer gamepad danke für die ganzen subs ich habe
ich jetzt nur noch mal erwähnt weil ich mir nicht sicher bin ich habe bestimmt wieder
irgendwer vergessen das soll ja nicht sein jetzt noch datenbank einbauen ja das ist natürlich
dann ein bisschen schwieriger jetzt noch automatische tests ja da gibt es verschiedene
möglichkeiten wie man das mit automatischen tests machen kann man könnte es über pull requests
regeln also quasi ob loss cute app man würde es ja über pull request normalerweise lösen also
aktuell habe ich die sachen immer nach master gepusht dann würde ein pull request erstellen
und da könnte ich ja dann auch irgendwelche actions hinten dran hängen die meine tests
suite laufen lassen noch zusätzlich irgendwelche sachen checken und vielleicht die genehmigung von
irgend wem einholen und sowas in der richtung also normalerweise wird es ja nicht direkt den
über den pull request da könnte ich an der stelle die ganzen sachen schon abfackeln
wie macht er das rolling update du hast von auto update gesprochen das macht agro selber
gar nicht das macht kuba nades das ist ja quasi so eines der großen vorteile weshalb man kuba
verwendet weil es sowas relativ gut out of the box kann und zwar macht man das hier drüber
und stellt ihr ein wie viele pots du von diesem typ laufen lassen will also sagen wir mal wie
viele container du laufen lassen willst also sie haben ich sechs stück eingestellt wir haben sechs
pots sechs mal die anwendung also wenn ich jetzt wenn ich jetzt her gehe und sag ich will ich will
zwölf haben können wir jetzt ja mal just for fun können wir das ja mal machen ja mach ich will
zwölf pots alles was ich da jetzt für jetzt machen muss ist das repo noch mal pushen mit
der endung und ihr werdet sehen gleich gleich so in paar paar sekunden also in zehn 15 sekunden
eskaliert automatisch hoch auf zwölf pots und das ganze hier ihr seht ohne ausfall macht er das
so und wie das funktioniert das sieht auch ja du hast eine ab deployed ja genau das habe ich auch
gemacht ich habe die pläne aber ohne die ganzen pentschamp den man da sonst so dabei hat ich
habe einfach nur gepusht die app wird ausgerollt der neuste version stack wird ausgerollt ohne
jegliche service unterbrechung und ohne dass ich großartig was machen muss ist einfach da und das
ja ich habe die pläne ist eigentlich das kuhlach das so easy ist ich muss bei komplizierteren
sachen aufpassen guck und schon einmal zwölf pots und es ist nichts passiert wir können auch
runter skalieren wir können auch wieder auf sechs pots runter skalieren oder auf drei
können sagen okay normalerweise wird man das nicht von hand machen aber ich zeigte es jetzt
mal lasst ihr auf der arbeit datenbank im cluster laufen ich bin mir nicht sicher ob wir nicht
vielleicht doch irgendwo datenbank im cluster haben durchaus durchaus möglich also im kubernetes
cluster red ich jetzt datenbank cluster selbst ja haben wir aber im kubernetes bin ich mir nicht
sicher ob wir da nicht doch irgendwo was haben zumindest habe ich es bis jetzt noch nicht gesehen
ist auch ein bisschen kompliziertes thema also also in dem fall würde ich tatsächlich sagen wenn
man eh schon all in cloud geht kann man auch gucken hat runter skaliert auf drei dann würde
ich irgendeine cloud datenbank verwenden und jetzt erklärt man wie das mit state voll anwendung
funktioniert je nachdem würde einen state speicher relativ easy weil du das in irgendeiner beim
cloud anbieter gehorsten datenbank macht es wird ein bisschen komplizierter und das sollte man
vielleicht an der stelle erwähnt es wird ein bisschen komplizierter wenn du beispielsweise
das in der mannage post crest und müsste es jetzt eine datenbank migration machen bevor die
neue anwendung läuft da musst du auf jeden fall sicherstellen dass die alten app versionen also
dass das neue schema für die datenbank kompatibel bleibt mit dem datenbank schema ansonsten musste
machen sonst kompliziert normalerweise fügste aber sachen also wenn du nur sachen hinzufügst
es ist ja kein problem wenn du das datenbank schema irgendwie kompatibel machst musste musste
dir was überlegen cooler ist es natürlich du benutzt irgendeine von deinem cloud anbieter
angebotene no sql datenbank ohne irgendwelche migrations und sonst was dann ist es easy du
kannst storage kannst du erst drei verwenden kannst du auf sich erstellen das instant der
neues data ist also die alten part so lange also die alten pot so lange oft sind ne also
ich kann es das machen aber der sinn im zweck ist ja eigentlich dass die anwendung nicht weg ist
so wie es jetzt aktuell eingestellt ist also wenn du irgendwie irgendwelche synchronen datenbank
migration brauchst die in kompatibel zur alten version sind ja dann dann musste wahrscheinlich
kurz runterfahren habe ich so auch noch nicht gemacht aber da musste wahrscheinlich kurz kurz
abschalten weil ansonsten werden die leute ja fehler kriegen die auf den alten der alten
app version sind jetzt bestimmt irgendwelche coolen lösungen für man kann und das hat auch
letztens einer im stream geschrieben man kann ja irgendwie wenn man richtig krasse dba hat die
können irgendwie auf das neue schema irgendwie so ein overlay pappen dass die alte apps da drauf
gemapt wird frag mich nicht keine ahnung habe ich keinen plan von wie sagt agon an dem kubernetes
dass ein neues docker image da ist ich das trägst du ein das trägt sich du trägst hier
die tech version ein dass du das nicht selbst machen muss gibt es gibt es bots die das für
dich machen zum beispiel also auf auf github den habe ich vorher schon geschlossen auf github
habe ich hier beispielsweise in bot laufen der festgestellt hat was ich dass ich von version 2
auf version 3 updaten kann das wird so in deinem das wird so ein jammel eintragen du würdest
das hier reinschreiben und das pusht du dann im git deine cluster konfig und ago erkennt es gibt
eine neue klasse cluster konfig und applied die dann und da ist halt die der change drin
warum benutzt du nicht die pender bot kann er das nicht ich glaube das hier kann er aber
er kann manche andere sachen nicht also was die pender bot meines wissens nach nicht kann ist
zum beispiel diese version hier erkennen renovate ist ein ist ist ist mehr richtung also hat mehr
support für so für so kubernetes manifest feinheiten drinne ich bin mir übrigens gar
nicht sicher ob die pender bot überhaupt kubernetes manifest gescheit kann weiß ich nicht habe ich
noch nicht ausprobiert so aber um auf die ursprungsfrage mal zurück zu bekommen von
war das glaube ich wie das mit dem rollout funktioniert das definierst du hier in deiner
app jammel und sagst wie viele container du laufen lassen haben möchtest von dieser app oder beziehungsweise
viele pots sind ja eigentlich und hier kannst du ihm sagen wie er das update durchführen soll
rolling ab ich glaube rolling update könnte sogar die fall sein also recreate
ach guck mal hier da hat sich die frage schon beantwortet eben die im chat gestellt wurde
wer hat das eben gefragt ob man die alten pots auch alle abschießen kann ja das geht natürlich
auch du kannst auch sagen recreate dann kannst du sicherstellen dass alle alten versionen aus sind
und die neue gestattet kannst du machen dann hast du halt kurzen service kurze service downtime was
warst du bei einer incompatible datenbank migration wahrscheinlich nicht groß vermeiden
kannst aber damit hätte sich das auch erledigt du würdest als rollout strategie oder als update
strategie würdest du einfach recreate hinstellen einstellen dann würde er nicht die sachen
nacheinander starten sondern alles auf einmal ja das habe ich mir letztens letztens schon
angeguckt in dem video ich habe es noch nicht so genau gecheckt was das jetzt genau sein soll
so und hier kannst du einstellen wie er das update machen soll also du stellst
erstmal den typ auf rolling update und dann kannst du einstellen wie er dieses rolling
update machen soll so und dann gibt es es gibt glaube ich nur diese zwei optionen max
unavailable und max search wenn ich das jetzt richtig aus dem kopf hinkriege bedeutet das
folgendes max unavailable bedeutet zum upgraden darf er von sechs also das hier oben ist dein
zielwert so viel möchtest du laufen haben so sechs pots also diese anwendung sechs mal diese anwendung
über deinen kubernetes cluster verteilt möchtest du laufen haben ok max unavailable bedeutet er
darf einen von diesen sechs ausmachen um einen neuen pot zu erstellen und max search bedeutet
er darf einen mehr haben so wie wir es jetzt hier eingestellt haben heißt er darf runtergehen auf
fünf zum ausschalten und gleichzeitig quasi irgendwie ein zusätzlich weil ich könnte ich
könnte jetzt ja auch so was machen ich muss euch ehrlich sagen so genau sicher bin ich mir jetzt
bei den bei den settings an der stelle nicht ich könnte auch so was machen dann müsse dann
würde er alle da lassen und erst eine neun erstellen und dann den alten abschalten sodass
du immer sechs stück am laufen hast so geht es halt ein bisschen schneller so geht es halt ein
bisschen schneller ja und hier so stellst du das ein wie er das wie er das update machen soll so
ich habe jetzt ich habe jetzt gesagt er soll wieder hoch skalieren auf sechs pots ich
pushe das ganze und demnächst so nach spätestens 15 sekunden sollte das ganze dann machen und was
jetzt auch sehr nice daran ist es ist alles getrackt in unserem git repo also ich kann jetzt jeden
einzelnen change nachgucken und dadurch dass ich argocd so eingestellt habe dass der automatisch
alle changes immer direkt singt aus dem git repo wenn jetzt jemand von hand hingeht und an
der anwendung irgendwas rumbaut argocd skaliert natürlich auch dann singt er das halt einfach
das nächste mal drüber das heißt du musst deine changes auch über pull requests oder oder halt
machen also du wirst quasi ein bisschen dazu gezwungen alles nachvollziehbar zu machen was
ich eigentlich ganz cool finde jede jede endung an unserem kompanie des cluster ist jetzt nach
vollziehbar du siehst jetzt ok so ist so ist die entwicklung von mein das ist ziemlich bescheuert
ok aber so ist die entwicklung von der anzahl meiner meiner pots für für cute app der wubblers hat
irgendwie hier gesagt er will wieder sechs stück haben da vorne gesagt er wird von 12 auf drei
runter da vorne gesagt von 12 auf sechs da vorne das image angepasst der typ hat keine ahnung was
er macht aber man kann es schön nachvollziehen und du hast ja eben gesehen dass alles funktioniert
ohne dass das service ausfällt das ist das ist schon wirklich nice kann man nicht kann man nicht
anders sagen wir können jetzt ja vielleicht um die frage aus dem chat noch mal zu beantworten wir
machen jetzt einfach mal recreate an der stelle rein und gucken uns das an wie das aussieht
gehen wir hoch auf 12 so ich würde jetzt erwarten dass der alle sechs pots beendet
und dann 12 neue erstellt gucken wir mal das habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert usch
gucken wir mal rein also wie gesagt ich habe ein intervall eingestellt von 15 sekunden wo
danach guckt ob es neue changes gibt das heißt wir müssen maximal 15 sekunden warten
oder sollte jetzt eigentlich alle sachen abschießen hoffe ich mal
time ausstarten
warum macht er das jetzt nicht habe ich vielleicht habe ich irgendwo ein
sündungsfehler eingebaut aus versehen können wir nachgucken ob ich den sündungsfehler eingebaut
habe können wir nachgucken und zwar können wir in unserem argo cd wo ist es am start argo cd
ok es geht nicht weil one or more objects failed sehr schön nice one or more objects
failed to apply reason invalids back rolling upgrade ist verbitten wenn der type recreate
ist ok das ergibt auch irgendwo sinn also ich kann nicht sagen ich kann nicht sagen options
für rolling upgrade wenn der typ nicht rolling upgrade ist ergibt sinn löschen wir das ganze mal
pushen es nochmal und hoffen dass jetzt das upgrade funktioniert sollte sollte gleich gleich
anlaufen wenn nicht können wir noch mal nachgucken was er jetzt für schmerzen hat
da würde sich jetzt beispielsweise anbieten noch innen also innen innen get hook oder
irgendwas zu haben was was so einen check macht ist halt blöd weil man direkt nach
master committed immer ok ich habe ich habe noch in den sündungsfehler drin warum auch immer
rolling update ist in wie verarschen rolling update ist nicht invalid
ach der hängt noch ok ich muss das alte erst mal abbrechen ok verstehe jetzt hat es funktioniert
gut ok man muss aktiv das alte erst mal abbrechen das ist dass man sich die
fehlermeldung angucken kann wahrscheinlich gut so eskaliert hoch er hat alle alten beendet
und die neuen erstellt ok
ja so sieht aus leute weil ich glaube es ist spät oder er hat die alten nicht beendet er
ist schlau er hat die alten nicht beendet weil er erkannte dass es die gleiche version ist
ergibt doch auch sinn ergibt doch auch sinn er hat die alten weiter laufen lassen und sechs
neue erstellt ich bin mir relativ sicher wenn ich eine neue app version eintragen würde dann
würde er das so machen ich glaube der ist einfach zu feifett rollback rollback ist easy kommt wir
machen man rollback auf version 4 ja wer ist hier und wer ist hier und 5 ist verbugt
mal gucken was jetzt passiert
jetzt mach mal hinne ich muss gleich pennen aha alle aus guck der ist feifett alle aus
und dann und dann kommen die neuen pots jetzt wäre der service down das ist halt der unterschied
zwischen recreate und rolling update bei rolling update hat er das problem nicht
jetzt ist es recreate ist logischerweise kein zero downtime aber es geht trotzdem schnell
aber das war eben die frage im chat wie das wie das aussieht
da ist oder es gibt gehalskürzung wenn ihr einer gehalt gekürzt kriegt dann ist es ich
glaube der präse rief sogar irgendjemanden wissen wollte was passiert oder was kann man machen dass
alles aus ist beim upgrade schlechtes app design dann tragen wir jetzt wieder rolling upgrade ein
und gehen wir da runter auf 6 und das ist das letzte was wir heute machen das warst du nicht
ich habe sie nicht mal genau im kopf wer es geschrieben hat
immutable bite was macht kupa netas genau guck hier jetzt hör mir jetzt lässt er die jetzt
machte die im pferd die runter die anderen jetzt ist auch zero downtime und jetzt noch
mal zero downtime deployment als letzte abends handlung so ich habe schon rückgängig gemacht
ok jetzt wird geupgraded wieder auf die neueste version zero downtime upgrade man sieht man
landet mal auf neuen containern mal auf alten containern wats cs dankeschön für den zap
gleich haben wir unser update durch
zack upgrade durch easy kein downtime also was kupa netas genau macht also wenn ich das jetzt
in paar setzen ohne die garten ohne das riesige ökosystem und alles was man damit machen kann
dass auch das was es kompliziert macht wenn ich es wenn ich mal ein paar setzen zusammenfassen
müsste man könnte quasi sagen dass kupa netas ein geklastertes docker ist eine container
orchestrierungs lösung die für dich geklastert container verwaltet also es ist quasi ein
cluster docker wenn man simpel zusammenfassen will wo du dann zum beispiel sowas machen kannst
wie was ich hier gerade gezeigt habe versions updates automatisch der reihe nach ausführen
auf containern ohne dass das service weggeht ohne dass das service nicht zur verfügung steht
damit kann man quasi viele docker leichter verwalten naja es ist man kann es so nicht
direkt vergleichen also es ist nicht so dass du dann fünf mal docker laufen hast also kupa
netas selbst benutzt glaube ich intern gar nichts gar nichts mehr von docker also die
hatten mal eine zeit lang docker als container runtime ich glaube das ist mittlerweile komplett
raus das gibt es gar nicht mehr du kannst mit kupa netas quasi genauso wie mit docker container
starten und stoppen aber du kannst das besser koordinieren also du hast da nicht nur ein
docker eine docker instanz mit ein paar container macht die lokal laufen ganz
besser koordinieren du kannst zum beispiel kannst du beispiel das ganze so orchestrieren
dass du verschiedene notes hast in deutschland verteilt und du sagst dann ok ich möchte
das sicherstellen dass meine anwendung zwölf mal vorhanden ist und dann wird die dann über
alle deine drei kupa netas cluster notes in deutschland verteilt und dann kannst du
quasi zentral upgrades ausrollen lassen du kannst ganz zentral konfig managen und auch
benutzerberechtigung vergeben für admins und tools und alles mögliche es ist quasi
ein gecluster das hoch verfügbares docker das trifft es eigentlich ganz gut
bot dankeschön für den sub pogo so nächstes mal geht es weiter dann müssen wir wirklich mal
das bisschen erweitern noch um eine runde monitoring wir machen noch in github einen
check ob unsere manifest fehlerhaft sind hast du schon mal was mit docker swarm gemacht nein
habe ich nicht und ich bin auch vorbeigekommen ich hätte um ein haar mein arbeitgeber gewechselt
ende ende december zu einem laden hin die docker swarm verwenden der hätt ich tatsächlich
mich mit docker swarm auseinandersetzen müssen als nix immer auch her und nicht super geheim
max next to do öffnen kannst du machen habe ich denn da drin
siehung search manager wir müssen uns auch sehr viel zeug angucken also was kupa netas content
angeht der wird uns in nächster zeit für den stream nicht ausgehen aber wir machen auch noch
andere streams können ich immer nur immer nicht kuban kuban nidesen ketsen können wir nicht wir
können nicht immer nur ketsen ja es ist der gel aber es benutzen immer noch ein paar wobei
ich weiß gar nicht ob es das ist im eigentlichen sinne weil ein oder anderen patches gibt es
wahrscheinlich immer noch für das ist ja das einzige was die die firma hinter docker da zu
bieten hat in der richtung doch er hat es bisschen verkackt muss man sagen also die firma hinter
docker die waren die ersten die in richtig cooles kontenerisierungs frontend gebaut haben und das
kann man ja nicht oft genug sagen docker und diese ganzen auch kuban nides diese ganzen
kontenerisierungsdinger das sind alles frontends für die gleiche linux kernel also für die gleiche
kontenerisierungsgeschichte im linux kernel es ist egal ob du docker potman oder kuban nides
nimmst oder der haube ist das das gleiche also so wie es dann wirklich ausgeführt wird das ganze
ökosystem drum herum wie baust du so einen image ja wo lädst du die images hin wie kannst du das
orchestrieren das ist was anderes aber so im kern das wie das ausgeführt wird das ist linux
container im kernel bei allem das gleiche sondern was docker gemacht hat ist die haben einen
kommando zeilen tun beziehungsweise ein frontend entwickelt das erste wirklich gute gescheite weit
verbreitende frontend für die körner für die für die container funktionalität im linux kernel
das ist das was docker gemacht hat und docker ist ja quasi jahrelang synonym mit linux
container benutzt worden heute immer noch aber heute muss man sagen bisschen bisschen weniger
zu dieses container gleich docker auch durch auch durch kuban nides und die haben es ein
bisschen verkackt die konnten dann nie so richtig kapital rausschlagen die hatten das verbreiteste
kontenerisierungstool die haben docker hab am start gehabt was die stelle war jeder benutzt hat
für seine images und selbst docker hab haben sie immer weiter gekürzt so dass niemand mehr
docker hab so richtig verwenden will letztens haben sie eine mail rum geschickt dass leute
die nicht bezahlen bald gelöscht werden und so was
ja deswegen am besten gleich am besten gleich kuban nides ja weiß ich hab ich gelesen den
vergleich finde ich immer noch sehr weit hergeholt trotz kap aber ich habe das auch ich habe das
auch schon ein paar mal gelesen letzter zeit gab es sogar auf youtube ein paar videos zu
ja
so sieht es aus leute schön dass jeder bei war drei stunden 15 kuban nides stels wie sieht es
aus wollen wir nach noch ein paar also wir machen demnächst noch ein paar andere streams ich kann
jetzt nicht jeden stream kuban nides stels machen wollen wir noch mehr kuban nides machen ich vermute
mal die antwort ist ja weil ich glaube euch gefällt das auch und ich lerne ja auch was bei
das ist eine gute kombination vor allem gerade gerade wenn ich die sachen erklären muss dann
muss ich mir da selbst noch ein bisschen gedanken darüber machen das wirklich nicht schlecht was
braucht man denn letztendlich alles an tools für kuban nides helmen ehrlich gesagt so zum
einstieg brauchst du gar nichts du brauchst noch nicht mal helmen zum einstieg ich persönlich
finde helmen auch ab also das was ich da bisher vorgesehen habe finde ich ziemlich abartig ich
mags nicht wirklich wenn ich irgendwas templaten will würde ich wahrscheinlich
eine ordentliche programmiersprache benutzen so was hier also wenn ich wirklich was bisschen
komplizierter zusammenstellen muss an manifest auch wenn agocd das nicht native kann ja ich
mein an helm kommt man nicht vorbei letztendlich wenn man third party anwendung installieren will
jeder jede anwendung hat einen helm chart zum installieren also insofern du brauchst ja du
brauchst das schon aber am anfang nicht wirklich wenn du mal einen kleinen lokalen cluster hinstellen
willst und darauf ein eigenes image deployen willst brauchst du kein helm für da reicht
eigentlich eigentlich schon ein jammelfile für kubectl apply und gut ist
am besten am besten kennst du dich mit beidem ein bisschen aus aber mir hat das nicht wirklich
wirklich zugesagt bisher manchmal kommt man nicht dran vorbei manchmal muss man muss man
sachen customisieren von leuten die helm charts schon für anwendungen die helm chart schon
erstellt haben oder vielleicht brauchst du mal wirklich simple templates oder so ist es
sinnvoll aber ich fand es sehr eklig alles was ich da bisher von gesehen habe
ich finde gar nicht so sehr dass customise versus helm diese diskussion großartig sinn macht mit
helm kannst du templaten mit customise nicht customise kannst du ein paar schreibarbeiten
erleichtern ja du kannst namespaces standardmäßig setzen und wenn du keine ahnung mehrere environments
haben willst ein paar sachen überschreiben aber das ergänzt sich doch eigentlich ganz gut
so quasi diese diskussion das customise was letztendlich hat beides eine daseinsberechtigung
man braucht auch beides wie gesagt ich bin kein großer helm zumindest charts selber selber
stellen hat es sich bei mir bisher noch nicht so die lust so eingestellt
ne morgen nicht morgen muss ich immer mal kreisel kreit machen und wir können auch nicht jeden
tag kubane das mal also leute wir sehen uns bis denn ich gehe jetzt oft bis denn zu